hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live in wenigen Minuten beginnt die
regierungsbefragung von Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz im Bundestag wir sind
deshalb für euch live denn heute kam die
Bestätigung die Bundesregierung will der
Ukraine den Kampfpanzer Leopard 2
liefern und nun warten alle ganz
gespannt auf die Antworten des Kanzlers
wir schauen hier auch gerade mal rein
behalten das für euch im Blick dass wir
direkt live drauf gehen haben vor allem
aber auch Zeit für eure Fragen und
Kommentare und geben euch eine Analyse
und hoffentlich auch viele Antworten
stellt gerne eure Fragen direkt im
Stream oder per Mail und jetzt ist auch
schon mal Zeit dafür bevor es losgeht
und bei uns meine Kollegin
Korrespondentin in Berlin Diana
Zimmermann hallo hallo
Diana was erwartest du heute von der
regierungsbefragung nachdem jetzt ja
endlich die Nachricht da ist gestern
schon durch Medienberichte angekündigt
erwartest du viel Lob für den Kanzler
für diese Entscheidung jetzt oder eben
auch massiv Gegenwind
ja ich denke das wird sich schön an den
fraktionslinien entlang entscheiden die
Opposition vor allen Dingen die Union
hat noch mal nachgehakt auch gestern als
die Medienberichte kam und sagte die
Entscheidung sei eben viel zu spät
gekommen sie hatte schon vergangene
Woche kommen müssen gemeinsam mit den
europäischen Partnern aber auch die
Kritiker in der Koalition Grüne und FDP
die lange getrieben hatten und den
Kanzler versucht haben zu drängen zu
einer Entscheidung die zeigten sich
heute sehr leichtert und froh und sagten
es sei ja nun doch gut dass die
Amerikaner gemeinsam mit den
europäischen Partnern auch bereit sein
Kampfpanzer zu liefern das war ja das
Ziel von Olaf Scholz das hat er von
Anfang an immer gesagt und insofern wird
er es glaube ich relativ leicht haben zu
verteidigen dass das jetzt etwas länger
gedauert hat weil nun die Allianz die
gemeinsamen Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine
schicken wird so viel größer geworden
ist du sprichst es an also das ist für
heute auch erwartet eben eine konkrete
Ansage noch mal der Amerikaner
durchgesickert ist da eben auch schon
das auch die Amerikaner ihren
Kampfpanzer Abrams liefern wollen manche
feiern kann man online auch lesen in den
Kommentaren Scholz jetzt als klugen
Strategen der diesen Deal gemeinsam
ausgehandelt hat und andere kritisieren
ihn nach wie vor für das Zögern was ist
da was hörst du aus Berlin was überwiegt
da denn jetzt
also
wie gesagt das ist eine wirklich eine
Frage die sich an den parteilinien
entscheidet ich selbst finde ist relativ
schwierig zu da Scholz irgendwas
vorzuwerfen er hat selbst einen Anspruch
formuliert zu Beginn des Krieges er
wollte auf keinen Fall deutsche
Alleingänge und er ist ganz
offensichtlich besorgt gewesen dieses
Risiko was er jetzt glaubt einzugehen
mit der Lieferung von Panzern möglichst
breit zu streuen auf viele Schultern zu
verteilen und da war es ihm sehr wichtig
und auch das hat er immer gesagt dass
die Natur die europäischen Partner aber
eben auch die USA mitmachen und das war
bis gestern Abend wohl nicht klar und
insofern glaube ich ist das für ihn ein
diplomatischer Erfolg ändert nichts
daran dass es lange gedauert hat dass es
viel Streit gab und die Kritik daran
dass er ist sich eben nicht getraut hat
als europäische Führungsmacht voran zu
gehen nicht also verstummt
und du sprichst sie an die
unterschiedlichen parteilinien je
nachdem wird man dann auch
unterschiedliches hören heute morgen
schon bei uns im ZDF MoMA haben wir die
Linken Chefin Whistler gehört die sagte
dort der Ukraine und den Menschen in dem
Land sei nicht geholfen wenn dieser
Krieg über die Ukraine hinaus eskaliere
und Zitat und wir in eine Rutschbahn
kommen die wirklich eine gefährliche
Eskalation bedeuten kann also erwartest
du auch die heftigste Kritik heute kommt
dann womöglich von den Linken
es gibt zwei zwei Sorten von Kritik im
Bundestag das eine ist eben die Union
die sagt das war alles viel zu langsam
und das andere ist die AFD und die Linke
die beide sagen es sei ein gigantischer
Fehler überhaupt deutsche Panzer nach
Russland zu schicken die Russen haben
heute auch reagiert gerade eben und
gesagt Deutschland habe seine
historische Verantwortung aufgegeben in
dem es nun eben wieder nach dem zweiten
weltkriegt deutsche Panzer in Russland
gibt das ist etwas das ähm in der
Diskussion hier nicht so eine Rolle
gespielt hat aber ich nehme an dass das
auch in der SPD ziemlich breit
diskutiert wurde eben diese Tatsache
dass deutsche Panzer in Russland etwas
sind wovor sehr viele zurückgeschreckt
haben auch wenn völlig klar ist dass die
Verantwortung für diesen Angriffskrieg
momentan in Russland liegt und nicht in
der Ukraine aber die AFD und die Linke
sagen eben das führe zu einer Eskalation
deshalb viel zu gefährlich die
Bundeswehr ohnehin nicht gut genug
aufgerüstet sagt vor allen Dingen die
AFD und die ganze Situation viel zu
instabil und gefährdet eben
die Bevölkerung der Bundesrepublik du
hast die ganze Debatte mit den Stimmen
jetzt vorab auch zusammengefasst schon
mal wir haben noch ein paar wenige
Minuten Zeit und schauen gemeinsam in
den Bericht
nun rollen sie also doch in die Ukraine
deutsche Leopard 2 Panzer und zwar nicht
nur solche die an Polen verkauft wurden
auch aus den Beständen der Bundeswehr
soll eine Kompanie etwa 14 Panzer die
Ukrainer bei der erwarteten
Frühlingsoffensive der Russen
unterstützen die offizielle Ankündigung
des Kanzlers wird am Mittag im Bundestag
erwartet die Opposition bleibt bei ihrer
Kritik begrüßen natürlich diese
Entscheidung aber wir bedauern dass es
zu einem Vertrauensverlust und zu einem
Zeitverlust geführt hat vor zwei Tagen
in Paris was wäre das für ein Zeichen
gewesen gemeinsam mit dem französischen
Präsidenten diesen Vorschlag zu machen
oder vor vier Tagen in Rammstein was hat
sich in den letzten vier Tagen geändert
womöglich entscheidendes seit gestern
bestätigen US-amerikanische
Parlamentarier das nun auch Joe Biden
bereit ist etwa 30 Kampfpanzer vom Typ
Abrams zu liefern lange hatte er dies
abgelehnt nun aber scheint das Drängen
des Bundeskanzlers Erfolg gehabt zu
haben immer wieder hatte Scholz betont
deutsche Alleingänge vermeiden und eine
breite Allianz unter Einschluss der USA
schmieden zu wollen Konsultation
brauchen zuweilen Zeit und dass die
Amerikaner jetzt mit an Bord gekommen
sind ist eine Folge und deshalb ist das
eine erleichternde Nachricht die man
muss natürlich jetzt abwarten dass der
Bundeskanzler das auch verkündet aber
die Berichte die wir jetzt sehen sind
erleichtern
Ukraine ist Präsident selenski forderte
umgehend mehr als nur 5 10 oder 15
Panzer neben Deutschland den USA Polen
und Großbritannien wollen wohl auch die
Niederlande Finnland und Norwegen
liefern offen ist wann und in welcher
Menge das schwere geschützt tatsächlich
an der Front eintreffen wird
über diese Diskrepanz zwischen
Erleichterung und Sorge dass Deutschland
jetzt also Kampfpanzer an die Ukraine
liefert können wir jetzt sprechen mit
Albrecht von Lucke erst
Politikwissenschaftler und Redakteur der
Blätter für deutsche und internationale
Politik hallo hallo Frau jung Herr von
Lucke die Frage die sich natürlich
aufdrängt wenn man jetzt auch die Laute
Kritik dann der Linken hört und von aber
auch unterschiedlichen Seiten ist diese
Sorge vor einer Eskalation des Krieges
aufgrund der Panzerlieferungen
berechtigt
die Sorge kann man nie völlig in den
Wind schlagen aber das muss man sehr
deutlich sagen auch durch die Tatsache
dass es Olaf Scholz gelungen ist
tatsächlich die Amerikaner an Bord zu
holen hat er die Wahrscheinlichkeit das
Russland hier tatsächlich zu einer
Eskalation drängt und auch sie drängt
und es zum Anlass nimmt regelrecht
maximal relativiert und reduziert das
ist auch ein sehr erstaunliches Phänomen
dass hier Linkspartei und AFD quasi über
jetzt wo Monate schon geschlossen quasi
die einzige Opposition darstellen die
absolut gegen Waffenlieferungen sind es
ist ja von Anfang an von der Linkspartei
aber auch noch mehr natürlich von der
AFD jeglichem Waffen Export
widersprochen worden aber dabei wird
permanent unterschlagen das ist längst
eine dezidierte ja durchaus kritische
Haltung selbst der Chinesen gibt schon
lange vielen ist das gar nicht so
bewusst gibt es Gespräche zwischen
Amerikanern und Chinesen bei denen auch
ausdrücklich China darauf drängt dass
man nicht eskaliert also war nicht auf
Russland einwirkt
Herr von Luca ich sehe den Bundeskanzler
wir haben ihn gerade gesehen neben ihrem
Kopf auch reinkommen in den Bundestag
wir schauen mal kurz gemeinsam wollen
den Moment nicht verpassen und ich würde
vorschlagen wir geben jetzt auch schon
mal ab live in den Bundestag sprechen
danach weiter mit euren Fragen
Punkte zu erweitern von der Frist für
den Beginn der Beratung soll soweit
erforderlich abgewichen werden heute
folgt nach der Fragestunde auf Verlangen
der Fraktion der cdu/csu eine Aktuelle
Stunde zu dem Thema leopardblockade der
Bundesregierung beenden kein Vertrauen
bei Verbündeten verspielen
am Donnerstag ist vorgesehen nach
Tagesordnungspunkt 6 den
Tagesordnungspunkt 18 aufzurufen
Tagesordnungspunkt 7 sowie die weiteren
Punkte 11 und 13 der
cdu/csu-fraktion verschieben sich
entsprechend nach hinten wobei
Tagesordnungspunkt 7 mit einer
geänderten debattenzeit von 39 Minuten
und Tagesordnungspunkt 13 mit einer
neuen debattenzeit von nunmehr 26
Minuten beraten werden soll
Tagesordnungspunkt 15 wird abgesetzt am
Freitag beginnt die Sitzung aufgrund der
Sonderveranstaltung anlässlich des Tages
des Gedenkens an die Opfer des
Nationalsozialismus um 11 Uhr
als erster Punkt sollen dann in
verbundener Beratung mehrere Vorlagen
zur Reform des Wahlrechts mit einer
debattendauer von 68 Minuten aufgerufen
werden
weiter ist vorgesehen den
Tagesordnungspunkt 19 abzusetzen ich
mache schließlich noch auf zwei
Überweisungen im Anhang zur
zusatzpunkte-liste aufmerksam
ich höre sehe keinen Widerspruch dann
ist das so beschlossen
ich rufe nun auf den Tagesordnungspunkt
1 Befragung der Bundesregierung die
Bundesregierung hat mitgeteilt dass
heute der Bundeskanzler Herr Olaf Scholz
zur Verfügung steht Herr Bundeskanzler
sie haben das Wort für ihre einleitenden
Ausführung
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Abgeordnete ich freue mich sehr dass ich
heute hier Ihre Fragen beantworten kann
und ich möchte gerne von der Möglichkeit
Gebrauch machen am Anfang etwas zu sagen
kurz bevor ich hierher gekommen bin habe
ich noch mit dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski gesprochen mit ihm
die gegenwärtige Lage beraten aber auch
das was Deutschland tut und tun wird
meine Damen und Herren wenn man die
Sorgen und Berichte über das letzte Jahr
noch einmal zurück in Erinnerung ruft
dann wird man sicherlich sagen können
alle meisten haben gedacht das wird wohl
nicht klappen dass wenn Deutschland kein
Gas aus Russland mehr bekommt wenn wir
Öl und Kohle komplett aus anderen
Quellen beziehen müssen dass das geht
ohne eine massive Wirtschaftskrise ohne
Versorgungsengpässe in dem jetzigen
Winter und ohne all die
Herausforderungen die damit verbunden
sind manche manche haben ja schon
gesprochen über einen wutherbst und ein
Wut Winter und ähnliche Dinge die unser
Land dann ereilen würden und mit denen
wir uns auseinandersetzen gehabt hätten
die Wahrheit ist dass es nicht
eingetreten wir sitzen hier es ist warm
und das ist auch überall in Deutschland
der Fall wir haben die Versorgung mit
Energie gewährleistet auch durch ein
ganz ganz neues deutschlandtempo mit
denen wir Infrastrukturen neu errichtet
haben und wir haben dafür Sorge getragen
dass wir auch die wirtschaftliche
Leistungskraft unseres Landes
unterhalten haben und die hohen
Preissteigerung für Energie zum Beispiel
ausgeglichen mit
entsprechenden milliardenschweren und
stückunterstützungs- und entlastungs-
man kann also mit einem Kommentator
sagen die Bundesregierung hat die
Wirtschaftskrise abgepfiffen wir sind
jetzt in einer besseren Lage der heute
vorgestellte Jahreswirtschaftsbericht
hat das auch noch einmal ganz deutlich
gezeigt und man kann auch ganz deutlich
sagen wir haben auch gezeigt was in uns
steckt und das ist mir ganz wichtig denn
es ist ja doch in kürzester Zeit
geschehen dass wir alle notwendigen
Maßnahmen ergriffen haben von dem wieder
in Betriebnahme von Kohlekraftwerken der
Verlängerung der Nutzung der
Atomkraftwerke über die Füllung der
gastspeicher und viele
importmöglichkeiten für Gast und bei
westeuropäische Häfen und dann eben neue
Terminals an den norddeutschen Küsten
die ersten drei haben schon die Schiffe
mit denen das Gas importiert werden kann
gewissermaßen gesehen und das ist ein
gutes Zeichen für Deutschland ich will
gerne an dieser
ich will gerne an dieser Stelle sagen
dass das Tempo dass wir hier gezeigt
haben ein Tempo sein muss das unser
ganzes Land prägt dass wir überall wo es
darum geht die Zukunft zu gewinnen mit
entsprechender Geschwindigkeit
Vorankommen zum Beispiel wenn wir jetzt
wo wir die Krise aktuell bekämpfen
mussten sehen wie schnell das geht dass
wir das auch machen wenn es darum geht
die erneuerbaren Energie Windkraft auf
hoher See an Land Solarenergie die
Stromnetze auszubauen wenn es darum geht
die Transformation der Industrie zu
begleiten damit tatsächlich gelingt was
wir uns vorgenommen haben das erste
CO2-neutral wirtschaftliche Industrie
Land der Welt zu sein als viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt voran zu
marschieren und zu zeigen das ist geht
und anderen damit auch den Mut zu machen
auch diesen Weg zu beschreiben
[Applaus]
vor allem haben wir den Zusammenhalt
nicht vergessen und den Respekt vor den
Bürgern und Bürgern mit all den
Leistungen die wir auf den Weg gebracht
haben meine Damen und Herren
meine Damen und Herren
Ursache für die Herausforderung die wir
zu bewältigen hatten was unsere eigene
Volkswirtschaft betrifft ist der
furchtbare imperialistische
Angriffskrieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine ein furchtbarer Krieg in dem die
Grundsätze auf die wir uns
jahrzehntelang in Europa verständigt
hatten in Frage gestellt worden sind die
Grundsätze die zum Beispiel diese
Aussage beinhaltet haben es darf nicht
mit Gewalt Grenzen verschoben werden es
dürfen Grenzen nicht mit Gewalt
verschoben werden das ist das was
Russland aufgekündigt hat das ist die
Zeitenwende von der hier in diesem
Bundestag gesprochen haben
[Applaus]
und deshalb ist es richtig dass wir eng
abgestimmt mit unseren internationalen
Partnern die Ukraine unterstützen
finanziell mit humanitären Mitteln aber
eben auch mit Waffenlieferung das haben
wir in einem Bruch mit jahrzehntelanger
Staatspraxis in Deutschland getan und
mittlerweile kann man sagen in Europa
sind wir es und Großbritannien die die
meiste Unterstützung mit Waffen für die
Ukraine zur Verfügung stellen und wenn
man fortrechnet was wir alles schon für
Entscheidungen getroffen haben kann man
sagen Deutschland wird immer vorne an
sein wenn es darum geht die Ukraine zu
unterstützen wir sind das Land dass das
mit großer Energie und in großem Umfang
tut
[Applaus]
dazu haben wir entschieden dass wir auch
schwere Waffen liefern die
Panzerhaubitze den mehrfach
Raketenwerfer was Artillerie betrifft
werden dem Flakpanzer Gepard zur
Verfügung gestellt und tun das weiter
ein modernes Luftabwehrsystem wie Iris t
wo gerade neue Flugkörper geliefert
worden sind und wir auch weitere Systeme
liefern werden das Patrick System wie
ich vor kurzem zusammen mit der
Regierung entschieden habe und das sind
alles Maßnahmen die dazu beitragen dass
die Ukraine sich verteidigen kann alle
diese Entscheidung haben wir im Einklang
und in enger Kooperation mit unseren
Verbündeten getroffen das ist der Grund
warum sie wirksam sind und warum wir sie
auch treffen konnten das ist das Prinzip
dass diese Regierung hat
und das werden wir weiter so halten wie
jüngst bei der Entscheidung zusammen mit
den USA Schützenpanzer zu liefern
Bradley die USA und wir mit unserem
Schützenpanzer marab Mader die Franzosen
haben zur gleichen zeitspielpanzer
bereitgestellt man sieht enge
Kooperationen und Abstimmung ist das
Prinzip und es ist richtig denn es ist
wirklich Krieg in Europa nicht weit weg
von hier in Berlin findet der statt
gegen ein großes Land wie die Ukraine
und deshalb müssen wir bei allem was wir
tun immer ganz klarstellen dass wir das
Notwendige und das mögliche machen um
die Ukraine zu unterstützen dass wir
aber gleichzeitig eine Eskalation des
Krieges zu einem Krieg zwischen Russland
und der NATO verhindern und dieses
Prinzip werden wir auch weiterhin immer
beachten
dabei gibt es für diese Dinge keine
mathematischen Gewissheiten keiner kann
einem erklären wo genau die richtigen
und die falschen Entscheidungen sind und
deshalb ist es richtig und mit vollem
Absicht geschehen dass wir uns Stück für
Stück vorangearbeitet haben und dieses
Prinzip werden wir auch in Zukunft
weiter verfolgen es ist das einzige
Prinzip das in einer so gefährlichen
Angelegenheit Sicherheit auch für Europa
und Deutschland gewährleistet
und das gilt jetzt auch für die jüngste
Entscheidung die die Bundesregierung
getroffen hat wir werden der Ukraine
auch Kampfpanzer zur Verfügung stellen
vom Typ Leopard 2
das ist das Ergebnis intensiver Beratung
erneut mit unseren Verbündeten und
internationalen Partnern und ich will
ausdrücklich sagen es war richtig und es
ist richtig dass wir uns nicht haben
treiben lassen sondern dass wir auf
diese enge Kooperation in einer solchen
Angelegenheit setzen und sie auch
fortsetzen
[Applaus]
unser Ziel ist es rasch bei
panzerbataione zusammen mit unseren
Verbündeten bereitzustellen das gibt
viele Länder die gerne mitliefern wollen
und wir werden das koordinieren und sie
einbeziehen damit das Schritt für
Schritt auch möglich wird Deutschland
wird wie gesagt Leopard 2 A6 Panzer zur
Verfügung stellen wird Leopard 2 R6
Panzer zur Verfügung stellen die aus den
Beständen der Bundeswehr stammen und
wenn die weiterhin das machen werden wir
die ukrainischen Besatzung hier in
Deutschland ausbilden wir werden
Ausbildung gewährleisten Logistik
Munition und Wartung der Systeme und wie
gesagt den Partnerländern ermöglichen
dass sie liefern können meine Damen und
Herren das ist das richtige Prinzip es
geht hier um sehr wirksame Waffensysteme
und es ist richtig dass wir diese
Waffensysteme niemals alleine sondern
immer in enger Kooperation bereitstellen
ein Wort zum Schluss es gibt in diesem
Land viele Bürgerinnen und die sich
Sorgen machen auch angesichts einer
solchen Entscheidung und angesichts der
Dimensionen die diese Waffe mit sich
bringt und deshalb möchte ich diesen
Bürgern und Bürgern hier und an dieser
Stelle sagen vertrauen Sie mir vertrauen
Sie der Bundesregierung wir werden
weiter weil wir international abgestimmt
Handeln sicherstellen dass diese
Unterstützung möglich ist ohne dass die
Risiken für unser Land darüber in eine
falsche Richtung wachsen das ist warum
wir das so tun und so werden wir es auch
weitermachen
[Applaus]
vielen Dank für die einleitenden Worte
und Herr Bundeskanzler wenn sie mich
beim nächsten Mal als sitzungsleitende
Präsidentin auch begrüßen werde ich sehr
dankbar unbedingt
wir beginnen jetzt mit der Befragung des
Bundeskanzlers und das Wort hat zuerst
aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion Jürgen hart
Präsidentin Herr Bundeskanzler
sie haben gestern über die Presse eine
Entscheidung bekannt gegeben da hätten
wir uns gewünscht dass das in Form einer
Regierungserklärung hier im Hause
erfolgt wäre wo man auch hätte darüber
debattieren können
aber seistum die Entscheidung war
richtig und auch der Kopf des
Bundeskanzlers ist rund damit die
Gedanken die Richtung ändern können
ich möchte an dieser Stelle aber darauf
hinweisen dass auf dem Weg zu dieser
Entscheidung einer erheblicher
Flurschaden entstanden ist und zwar noch
vor wenigen Tagen streitauer von der
Bühne mit Regierung aus dem Baltikum mit
Finnland die Polen haben noch gestern
eine bürokratische Antwort wird geprüft
bekommen auf Ihre Anfrage ob sie Panzer
liefern dürfen statt ein klares Ja der
französische Präsident macron hat in der
Rede in Lissabon wo sie beide ja
gesprochen haben gesagt man wird nicht
nur an den Entscheidungen gemessen die
man trifft sondern auch deren an denen
die man nicht trifft das ist ein
erheblicher politischer Flurschaden der
von Deutschland entstanden ist wer trägt
dafür die Verantwortung
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage und auch für
die Gelegenheit noch einmal vertieft auf
das Thema einzugehen und das will ich
gerne tun ich bin vollständig anderer
Meinung abgesehen davon dass wir die
Entscheidung heute getroffen haben sie
heute bekannt gemacht haben und
unmittelbar danach habe ich die erste
Gelegenheit genutzt hier im Deutschen
Bundestag etwas dazu zu sagen weil das
uns alle bewegt und das ist auch richtig
so
aber ich will Ihnen sehr klar sagen wenn
wir ihren Ratschlägen folgen würden wäre
das eine Gefahr für die Sicherheit
Deutschlands
viele Bürgern und Bürger fürchten sich
davor dass in der Weise regiert wird wie
sie vorschlagen
es wäre ein Fehler ein schlimmer ein
schwerer Fehler in dieser Frage alleine
voranzugehen alleine zu marschieren es
ist notwendig dass man sich miteinander
abstimmt und es ist ganz klar dass nicht
die letzte Pressemitteilung und die
nächste Pressemitteilung der Kalender
sind nachdem wir uns richten sondern das
was wir in enger Abstimmung mit unseren
Freunden und Verbündeten erreichen
können so muss man vorgehen wenn man
Frieden und Sicherheit für Europa und
Deutschland gewährleisten will und der
Ukraine helfen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben davon
gesprochen dass wir mit unseren
Unterstützung der Ukraine keine
Provokation gegenüber Russland ergreifen
wollen um den Konflikt Russland NATO
nicht Herr bereiten was ist eigentlich
mehr an einer Provokation Kampfpanzer im
Mai zu liefern als Panzerhaubitzen und
was ist jetzt anders im Januar des
Jahres 2023 das ist jetzt keine
Provokation ist in Anführungsstrichen
als dass sie das ja angesehen haben
gegenüber einer Entscheidung die
vielleicht letztes Jahr gemeinsam mit
Partnern getroffen worden wäre der
Abgeordneter ich habe das Wort
Provokation nicht in den Mund genommen
wenn es eine Provokation gibt dann ist
es die der russischen Regierung mit
ihren imperialistischen Angriffskrieg
sie greifen die Ukraine an und sich
Territorium anzueignen
[Applaus]
aber das will ich ganz klar sagen was
ist der Unterschied
wenn irgendjemand hier hingeht und
wirklich glaubt
das ist richtig wäre dass man hier nicht
Stück für Stück vorgehen muss dass man
rausfinden muss was geht dass man eng
mit an anderen abgestimmt handelt dass
man den ersten Schritt und den zweiten
Schritt und den dritten Schritt zur
richtigen Zeit tut dann wäre das nicht
gut für Frieden und Sicherheit in Europa
und deshalb sage ich wir werden haben
das nicht nur so gemacht eng abgestimmt
mit unseren besten Freunden und
Verbündeten wir werden es auch immer
weiter so machen
eine weitere Nachfrage aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion von dem Kollegen Hahn
dank frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen Herr Bundeskanzler
sie haben vor fast einem Jahr die
Zeitenwende hier beschworen zu Recht und
sie haben angekündigt die Bundeswehr zu
unterstützen mit 100 Milliarden und mit
einem dauerhaften Haushalt von zwei
Prozent von den Milliarden von den 100
Milliarden ist praktisch noch nichts
abgeflossen die 100 Milliarden schmelzen
in der Sonne von Inflation und von
Zinsen und die zwei Prozent sind weder
in einem aktuellen Haushalt noch in
einem Finanzplanung vorgesehen sie haben
außerdem gefordert vor kurzem dass
Deutschland Führungsrolle übernehmen
soll und wir die stärkste Armee in
Europa darstellen sollen ich frage mich
wann wollen Sie Ihr Wort tatsächlich
einhalten wie planen Sie tatsächlich
auch das was wir jetzt gerade abgegeben
haben zu Recht was wir begrüßen so
schnell wie möglich nach zu beschaffen
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage zunächst mal
in der Tat ich bekenne mich zu dem was
wir was ich gesagt habe hier im
Deutschen Bundestag unmittelbar nach dem
Ausbruch des Krieges Russlands gegen die
Ukraine bekenne mich zu dem was wir
miteinander beschlossen haben
dass errichtungsgesetz macht eine klare
Vorgabe dass wir im Mittel der Jahre
zwei Prozent der Wirtschaftsleistung für
die Verteidigung ausgeben wollen und ich
sage ich bekenne mich dazu ich möchte
das gewährleisten nicht nur dieser
sondern auch allen folgenden
Legislaturperioden dass das das Prinzip
ist in dem das gilt und mit dem 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen haben wir die
Grundlage dafür diesen fahrtwechsel auch
zu organisieren und zwar ohne uns von
lauten Rufen rechts und links davon
abbringen zu lassen die richtigen
Entscheidungen zu treffen was wir jetzt
brauchen sind konkrete Entscheidungen
für konkrete Systeme einige sind schon
getroffen dass die nukleare Teilhabe
betrifft mit dem F35 auch was an
Transporthubschrauber betrifft andere
sind unmittelbar bevorstehend und es
sind dann immer sehr langfristige
Verträge mit Produktion die manchmal
über Jahre dauert bis sie dann
stattfindet mit Munition und Ersatzteile
Lieferung und wir müssen alle in den
letzten Jahrzehnten Praxis gewordenen
Fehler beseitigen die die
Verteidigungsminister der cdu/csu auf
den Weg gebracht haben denn dazu trägt
ja nicht nur die Halbierung der
Bundeswehr und die Abschaffung der
Wehrpflicht dazu zählt auch das größte
Sparprogramm für die Bundeswehr unter
einer Verantwortung von konservativen
Politikern dass jemals stattgefunden hat
und dazu gehört selbstverständlich dass
wir all die Fehler korrigieren keine
langfristigen Verträge keine Ersatzteile
in ausreichender
Vorrätigkeit keine laufende Produktion
keine Situation mit ausreichender
Munition die ständig nachproduziert wird
und diesen Fehler in der engen
Zusammenarbeit zwischen Verteidigung und
Bundeswehr den werden wir beseitigen da
können Sie sich darauf verlassen
noch mal ein Appell an alle bitte die
Anfrage und Antwortzeiten
einzuhalten
auch Sie
nächste Frage aus der Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen von aneschka Brugger
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler es ist eine
richtige Entscheidung die das Kabinett
getroffen hat die Leopard-Panzer zu
liefern es ist vor allem eine dringend
gebotene Entscheidung wenn man sich
anschaut dass die unschuldigen Menschen
in der Ukraine nicht nur tagtäglich
unter den russischen Kriegsverbrechen
leiden sondern dass sie fürchten müssen
dass eine große massive russische
Großoffensive in den nächsten Wochen
kommt und mit
Luftverteidigungssystem aber eben auch
mit modernen Panzern leistet die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland hier ein
dringend notwendigen Beitrag für den sie
auch die Breite Rückendeckung aus der
demokratischen Mitte dieses Hauses haben
wie wir ja den ganzen letzten Wochen und
Debatten hier entnehmen können ich würde
sie gerne fragen
weil ja auch viel darüber spekuliert
worden ist den Leopard A1 aus den
industriebeständen zu liefern das die
Entscheidung ist jetzt Leopard
zwei A6 aus Beständen der Bundeswehr
natürlich müssen wir diese Lücken
schnell schließen ich begrüße das sehr
es ist ein starkes Zeichen auch von den
Fähigkeiten Herr richtig was hat sie zu
dieser Entscheidung bewogen ja schönen
Dank für die Frage wir haben uns
entschieden das was dann wirksamen
Mitteln zur Verfügung steht auch
einzusetzen das übrigens auch sorgfältig
vorbereitet denn sowohl das was wir hier
heute entschieden haben als auch die
Meinungsbildung unserer Partner sind ja
jetzt seit einiger Zeit vorbereitet
worden und noch mal der Kalender solche
Entscheidungen in anderen Hauptstädten
richtet sich nicht nach irgendwelchen
Ereignissen die hier in Deutschland oder
anders wo stattfinden deshalb ist es gut
dass wir das geschafft haben und für uns
war die Wirksamkeit sehr wichtig und wir
werden jetzt versuchen möglichst mit
vielen zusammen das erste Bataillon auf
einem hohen kampfniveau zur Verfügung
stellen und dann werden wir versuchen
damit umzugehen wenn weitere allerdings
nur frühere Waffensysteme was den
Leopard betrifft zur Verfügung stellen
können so dass das insgesamt aber eine
große Wirksamkeit gestaltet
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen vielen
Dank so richtig es ist dass diese sehr
schwerwiegenden Fragen die sich glaube
ich vom einfachen Abgeordneten bis zum
Bundeskanzler niemand einfach macht in
diesem Haus ist dass die öffentliche
Debatte eben sich sehr stark um die
Waffenlieferung dreht aber wir dürfen
unsere Solidarität und unsere
Unterstützung mit der Ukraine ja nicht
allein auf die Frage von Waffenlieferung
und Waffensystem so wichtig und dringend
geboten sie auch sind reduzieren wo
sehen Sie die größten Bedarfe für die
Zukunft die die Menschen in der Ukraine
von uns von der Europäischen Union von
transatlantischen Bündnis auch hier
weiter brauchen
schönen Dank für die Frage und ich
stimme Ihnen vollständig zu wir werden
die Ukraine mit Waffen unterstützen
solange und so sehr das notwendig ist
und gleichzeitig werden wir alles dafür
tun dass wir auch finanziell und
humanitär die notwendige Hilfe
bereitstellen das haben wir auch in der
Vergangenheit getan das sind schon sehr
große Milliardensummen die Deutschland
im letzten Jahr mobilisiert hat und wir
werden diesen Weg auch weitergehen das
wichtigste ist jetzt die
Energieinfrastruktur zu sichern und
dafür zu sorgen dass angesichts des
Vorwahl das ist
unerträglichen und völlig absurden und
unakt verzeihlichen bombardieren von
ihnen Energie Infrastruktur durch
Russland wir das helfen das wieder
aufzubauen und mit unserer
Luftverteidigung möglichst viele dieser
Angriffe zurück zu schlagen ermöglichen
und gleichzeitig wird es darum gehen
dass wir jetzt schon anfangen uns die
Gedanken über den Wiederaufbau der
Ukraine zu machen denn das ist doch was
wir hoffen dass dieser Krieg eines Tages
zu Ende geht dass die Ukraine Integrität
und Souveränität verteidigen kann aber
wird es noch viele Jahre und Jahrzehnte
brauchen wo die Weltgemeinschaft die
Ukraine beim Wiederaufbau unterstützen
muss und dazu haben wir alles auf den
Weg gebracht auch Konferenzen und
Strukturen etabliert damit das jetzt
schon in den Blick genommen wird
[Applaus]
nächste Frage stellt Petron aus der
afd-fraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kollegen sehr geehrter Kanzler sie
merken das schon an der bedrückten
Stimmung hier im Saal das ist ein
historischer Tag
sie haben gerade die Fundamente der
deutschen Außenpolitik der
Nachkriegszeit über Bord geworfen
und die besondere Verantwortung
Deutschlands für die
Opfer des Zweiten Weltkrieges war
sinnstiftend für die junge
Bundesrepublik und hier ging es
natürlich in erster Linie um die sechs
Millionen jüdische Mitbürger aber auch
um die 20 Millionen Frauen Kinder und
Männer die in der Sowjetunion getötet
wurden
und ihre großen
sozialdemokratischen Vorgänger Helmut
Schmidt und Willy Brandt haben sich in
besonderer Weise für den Frieden für die
Versöhnung eingesetzt und Willy Brand
hat dafür sogar den Friedensnobelpreis
bekommen
und nie wieder Krieg keine Waffen in
Kriegsgebiete das waren die Fundamente
deutsche Außenpolitik der Nachkriegszeit
die und diese diese Fundamente
danke danke liebe Herr Kollege ich
schließe mich denn an auch nie wieder
Faschismus
und genau genau diese Fundamente sie
sind diese Debatte überhaupt nicht
würdig wenn Sie hier weiter so
rumbrüllen wirklich kann der Kollege
seine Frage stellen die müsste er jetzt
auch bald stellen wegen der Zeit
und ansonsten
Konzentration auf die Befragung liebe
Frau Präsidentin ich hoffe doch sehr
dass sie mir jetzt diese Zwischenrufe
nicht von meiner Zeit abziehen
naja sie werden jetzt lieber Kanzler sie
werden jetzt in die Geschichte eingehen
als der Kanzler der dieses Vermächtnis
mit Füßen getreten hat und Millionen der
Bürger in diesem Lande fragen sich was
ist der Grund dafür dass sie das getan
haben was ist der Grund dafür dass ihr
eigenes Wahlversprechen gebrochen haben
was ist der Grund dafür dass sie jetzt
gegen die Mehrheit der eigenen
Bevölkerung handeln
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage eine falls
Sie mit Hilfe für die Ukraine
argumentieren die 14 die ganze Zeit aber
die 14 Panzer sind nicht Militär
entscheiden
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage ich will sie
auch klar beantworten ja es ist ein
Bruch mit all den großen politischen
Errungenschaften für die gerade Willy
Brandt und Helmut Schmidt stehen das
Russland die Ukraine angegriffen hat
denn dann Ergebnis ihrer Politik die als
Entspannungspolitik bezeichnet wird
waren ja auch am Ende die Vereinbarung
über die KSZE und die OSZE gemeinsame
Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in Europa
als Zielperspektive und dazu gehörten
zuletzt sogar sehr weitreichende
Aussagen zur Demokratie in den Staaten
aber ich konzentriere mich hier auf
einen anderen Aspekt dazu gehörte auch
die klare Aussage es wird nicht mit
Gewalt die Grenze verschoben die sich
historisch irgendwo ergeben hat
Russlands Angriffskrieg ist deshalb ein
imperialistischer Krieg weil er sagt ich
nutze meine macht und mich über das
Recht hinwegzusetzen ich habe irgendwo
in Geschichtsbüchern geblättert und
gesehen Grenzen waren mal anders
irgendwer spricht so ähnlich wie ich und
deshalb darf ich mit furchtbaren Bomben
Terror mit furchtbaren Waffeneinsatz ein
ganzes Land zerstören und angreifen um
mir davon was anzueignen das ist
Imperialismus das widerspricht den
Prinzipien für die Willy Brandt und
Helmut Schmidt standen und stehen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
natürlich Recht das ist ein
Parallelismus genauso wie die
NATO-Erweiterung und es wäre die im
Sinne im Sinne von Willy Brandt und
Helmut Schmidt wäre auch die Zusagen
einzuhalten eben die NATO nicht
auszuweitern aber die Frage ist sie
haben in ihrer Rede gesagt Sie wollen
die Ukraine unterstützen solange es
notwendig ist wie definieren Sie das
konkret also wann was sind die
Kriegsziele wann wollen Sie Schluss
machen mit den Waffenlieferungen ja wir
haben am Anfang über 5000 Helme
gesprochen jetzt sind das mittlerweile
Panzer Flugzeuge also was muss erreicht
werden was wann ist Schluss damit
Flugzeuge sind es nicht ich weiß nicht
warum sie das jetzt aufgezählt haben
aber wenn sie da was sehen dann
berichten Sie mir das mal also um es
jetzt ganz klar zu sagen wir haben sehr
weitreichende Unterstützung zur
Verfügung gestellt und werden das tun
damit die Ukraine ihre Integrität und
Souveränität verteidigen kann das
Kriegsziel
das Kriegsziel Russlands ist klar nicht
einfach einen Teil des Territoriums
anzueignen und das ist eben etwas was
uns unterscheidet wir sind nicht der
Meinung dass irgendein Land das
Hinterhof eines anderen der Hinterhof
eines anderen ist wir sind nicht der
Meinung dass Russland sagen kann ihr
dürft hier nicht über eigenes
staatsgeschehen entscheiden ihr dürft
keine Demokratie sein weil das gegen
meine Interessen verstößt und diese
imperiale Idee dass er in der Ukraine
mit regiert die ist ja das was ihn zu
diesem Krieg geführt hat und das werden
wir zurückzahlen das ist der Grund
unserer Unterstützung
[Applaus]
nächste Frage stellt Dr Marie Agnes
Strack Zimmermann aus der FDP-Fraktion
Herr Bundeskanzler das war eine wirklich
gute Nachricht die heute auch bestätigt
wurde von ihnen dass die Bundesregierung
den Weg frei gemacht hat Leopard 2
Panzer an die Ukraine zu schicken es war
vor allen Dingen eine gute Nachricht für
die Menschen in der Ukraine die wie sie
ja gerade auch gesagt haben seit elf
Monaten geknechtet werden an der Stelle
erlauben Sie mir auch Herrn Pistorius
den neuen Verteidigungsminister herzlich
zu gratulieren wir hatten gerade
Gelegenheit uns im Ausschuss
auszutauschen
Herr Bundeskanzler sie sprachen gerade
zu Recht von einem breiten Bündnis
eingebettet wir als Deutsche in der
Europäischen Union aber auch Teil der
NATO vielleicht könnten Sie hier noch
mal ein bisschen konkretisieren wer an
der Stelle besonders mit uns
zusammenarbeitet wo es Länder gibt wo es
vielleicht noch Überzeugungsarbeit
benötigt wir haben ja sehr
unterschiedliche Länder in dem großen
Bündnis ich glaube das würde die Arbeit
auch in der Gemeinsamkeit in Zukunft
auch verbessern
schönen Dank für diese Frage zunächst
mal kann ich ja sagen dass man das was
wir machen aus der Vergangenheit
hochrechnen kann weil wir immer
konsequent und immer gleich gehandelt
haben alle wichtigen Entscheidungen was
jetzt besonders wirksame Waffen betrifft
etwa die Panzerhaubitze etwa der
mehrfach Raketenwerfer etwa die
Möglichkeit mit ihres Tee oder vor
einiger Zeit die Entscheidung zu Patriot
und dem Marder haben wir getroffen
nachdem unsere wichtigsten Bündnisse im
Norden Amerika bundespartner im Norden
Amerikas und hier in der Europäischen
Union entsprechend und ähnlich gehandelt
haben und so werden wir auch weiter
vorgehen und deshalb war es notwendig
dass wir Zeit investieren für eine
koordinierte Vorgehensweise die
natürlich jeder für sich und vor seiner
Öffentlichkeit erklären muss deshalb
gestanden sie dass ich den
entsprechenden Aussagen anderer hier
nicht vorgreifen will aber sie haben ja
schon mitbekommen wir sind nicht alleine
und das ist das im Prinzip dass wir auch
in der Zukunft weiter gelten lassen
werden ein Satz noch zur Unterstützung
durch viele andere das wird jetzt ganz
interessant werden übrigens auch für
diejenigen die sich besonders
hervorgetan haben in öffentlichen
Diskursen der deutschen Innenpolitik
teilzunehmen dass Hick Rhodos hicksalter
heißt dass man auch dann substanziell
was beiträgt darum werden wir uns
bemühen
die
Nachfrage stellen ja es war eine Frage
wir sind gemeinsam der Meinung dass es
auch das eine sehr gute Nachricht ist
Fragezeichen
dass wir im Bündnis sind und das eben
auch andere Partner uns anschließen in
den nächsten Monaten neben
wirtschaftlicher humanitärer militärisch
auch die Ukraine zu unterstützen
dazu haben wir immer alle ermuntert und
was jetzt die konkrete Situation
betrifft werden wir auch alle dazu in
die Lage versetzen nicht nur was das
einfachste ist und ja auch logisch aus
unserer eigenen Entscheidung folgt dass
wir ihn gestatten wenn sie solche
wirksamen Waffen auch zur Verfügung
haben sie zu liefern sondern dass wir
auch gesagt haben wir fühlen uns mit
verantwortlich das zusammenzustellen
dafür zu sorgen dass die Kräfte
gebündelt werden dass das klappt mit
Ersatzteilen Munition und der Ausbildung
in Deutschland
nächste Frage stellt aus der Fraktion
DIE LINKE Matthias W birkwald
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler gestanden
sie mir bitte einen Themenwechsel
jenseits des uns alle zu Recht
bewegenden russischen angriffskriegs auf
die Ukraine habe ich eine
rentenpolitische Frage zu einem Thema
das sehr viele Menschen in unserem Land
bewegt auch wenn es bei dieser Frage
nicht um Leben und Tod geht
Herr Bundeskanzler ich habe mit Freude
aber auch mit Verwunderung so wie viele
Millionen direkt Versicherte auch ihre
Aussage vom 1 September 2022 bei einem
Bürgerdialog in Essen vernommen dass sie
für das Problem der doppelverbeitragung
der Direktversicherungen und der
Betriebsrenten mit
Krankenkassenbeiträgen noch in dieser
Legislaturperiode und ich darf sie
zitieren eine irgendwie fiskalisch
mögliche Lösung Zitat Ende finden werden
deshalb im Namen von sechs Millionen
direktversicherungsgeschädigten bitte
ich sie nachdrücklich darum dies hier im
Hohen Hause erneut zu bestätigen und ich
frage Sie höflich aber mit Nachdruck zu
welchen Zeitpunkt und vor allem in
welcher Form beabsichtigen Sie das
Problem nun endlich konkret lösen zu
wollen danke in der Tat ein Thema das
viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger umtreibt
deshalb finden sie das ja auch in den
Verständigung die wir zur
Regierungsbildung hier gefunden haben
unter den drei Regierungsparteien wieder
als Auftrag das ist allerdings kein
trivialer auf gesagt deshalb ist es so
dass noch hart darüber nachgedacht wird
wie man das konkret gestalten kann aber
das ist ja etwas dass wir uns auch
vorgenommen haben und Sie können sich
darauf verlassen wir werden auch mit
Lösungen arbeiten
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen das
freut mich danke für Ihre Antwort ich
will doch einmal nachfragen ob es denn
auch schon konkrete Schritte
beispielsweise Gespräche mit zuständigen
Ministern gibt wo man zumindest einen
Zeitplan erwarten kann und ob sie bei
ihren Überlegungen dann auch darüber
nachdenken die mehrfach Verbeitragung
sofort zu stoppen unter anderem auch als
finanzielle Entschädigung für die
Betroffenen in deren Verträge ja mit dem
Gesundheits modernisierungsgesetz
millionenfach eingegriffen worden ist
und eben auch in die Richtung Halbierung
der Beiträge von Kranken- und
Pflegeversicherung bei Betriebsrenten
und Direktversicherungen also eine
Beschränkung auf den Arbeitnehmeranteil
wie bei der gesetzlichen Rente ob sie
das in ihre Überlegungen einbeziehen für
die Laufenden
Beitragszahler haben wir bereits in der
letzten Legislaturperiode wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere entsprechende
Verbesserung auf den Weg gebracht und
ich weiß deshalb aus der fachlichen
Auseinandersetzung mit diesem Thema als
ich noch das Finanzressort vertreten
habe dass das alles gar nicht so einfach
ist und deshalb haben wir uns zunächst
mal auf die Frage konzentriert was macht
man mit den aktuellen die Lösung ist
jetzt Gesetz geworden und für viele eine
Verbesserung und da haben wir ja
natürlich noch die Frage für die
Vergangenheit und die ist eben nicht so
trivial
nächste Frage stellt aus der
SPD-Fraktion dr Nils Schmid
Präsidentin Herr Bundeskanzler zunächst
mal will ich glaube ich auch im Namen
von vielen hier im Haus sprechen und
Dank und Anerkennung aussprechen für
diese abgewogene Entscheidung zu
aktuellen Waffenlieferung herzlichen
Dank dass Sie das auch heute im
Deutschen Bundestag erläutert haben
sie haben deutlich gemacht dass die
Bundesregierung sich an ein paar wenigen
klaren Prinzipien orientiert wie man bei
dieser durchaus sensiblen Frage vorgeht
gemeinsam mit verbündeten unter
ständiger Abwägung der Risiken und
natürlich mit voller so Unterstützung
für die Souveränität der Ukraine wir
haben leider in den letzten Tagen
zahlreiche Gerüchte lesen können über
die deutsch-amerikanischen Beziehungen
können Sie vielleicht einiges zu der
Abstimmung wieder amerikanischen
Regierung sagen natürlich nicht über
mögliche Waffenlieferung aber um
vielleicht der Deutsche Bundestag
mitzuteilen wie es tatsächlich um diese
Abstimmung steht
ja also schönen Dank für die Frage ich
kann Ihnen sagen dass die Beziehung
zwischen der bundesdeutschland USA auf
einem so guten Niveau sind wie
wahrscheinlich schon ganz lange nicht
mehr ich empfinde große große
Übereinstimmung mit dem amerikanischen
Präsidenten die nicht für einen sehr
fähigen sehr orientierten sehr
zielsicher handelnden Politiker halte
gerade was die internationale Politik
betrifft und was die Unterstützung der
transatlantischen Beziehungen und den
Wert auf das Wert legen auf eine gute
Zusammenarbeit mit Deutschland betrifft
ist das ein Präsident der ein wirklich
guter Partner ist
deshalb sind meine Gespräche mit dem
Präsidenten immer sehr freundlich und
dann habe ich in irgendwelchen Medien
Veröffentlichung was über Gespräche
gelesen die andere geführt haben das war
alles mehr oder weniger nicht mit der
Wirklichkeit vereinbaren aber die
Gespräche waren auch freundlich
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen Herr
Bundeskanzler der wichtigste Verbündete
Deutschlands innerhalb Europas ist
Frankreich es gibt eine enge Abstimmung
mit der französischen Regierung bei der
Unterstützung der Ukraine insbesondere
auch mit Blick auf den EU Beitritt es
gab ein deutsch-französische Ministerrat
am Wochenende können Sie was sagen was
mit der französischen Seite zur weiteren
Unterstützung der Ukraine vereinbart
worden ist wir haben natürlich über
diese Fragen gesprochen und sind uns
einig dass wir die Ukraine weiter
unterstützen werden mit all dem was
notwendig ist auch mit
finanziellen humanitären Mitteln und
Waffen sie haben ja schon gesehen dass
beim letzten Mal die Entscheidung im
gleich
quasi zum gleichen Zeitpunkt erforscht
ist was jetzt Deutschland USA mit
Bradley und Marder betrifft und dann den
spielpanzer der Franzosen und wir sind
auch jetzt verabredet hier gemeinsam zu
agieren
nächste Frage stellt Robert Vahle
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
mir geht es eigentlich um ein einziges
Problem noch nämlich
auf Twitter hat Herr Melnik gefordert
also ich zitiere wörtlich mit ihr
Genehmigung und nun liebe Verbündete
lasst uns eine starke kampfjet-koalition
für die Ukraine auf die Beine stellen
mit F16 und F35 Eurofightern unter nados
Raffaele und ich weiß nicht wie man das
nennt greifen Chats oder creepen Chats
und allen was ihr der Ukraine liefern
könnt und meine Frage ist einfach nur
wenn dann Forderungen auf Bodentruppen
kommt irgendwo muss dann ja Schluss sein
sondern es muss ja irgendwo mal die
Grenze erreicht sein wo man sagen kann
das gehört nicht mehr zur Unterstützung
einer Verteidigung und Frau bärburg hat
gestern in der Parlamentarischen
Versammlung des Europarats gesagt wir
kämpfen einen Krieg gegen Russland und
nicht gegeneinander und meine Bitte ist
einfach dass sie erläutern das kann ja
wohl niemals die und die Position dieser
gesamten Bundesregierung sein und ich
habe immer hinter ihnen gestanden wenn
sie Sachen rauszögern die nicht
unbedingt notwendig sind mehr will ich
nicht sagen aber Herr Falle die Zeit
okay ja vielen Dank für die Frage ich
will aber sehr klar sagen unsere
Prinzipien sind so wie ich sie erläutert
habe und ja ja die Entscheidung die wir
jetzt gerade getroffen haben ist eine
bei der natürlich viele Bürgerinnen und
Bürger sich Sorgen machen und deshalb
noch mal was ich versucht habe mit
meinem eingangstatement zu sagen
vertrauen Sie der Regierung vertrauen
Sie auch mir wir werden uns weiterhin
nicht von öffentlichen Druck und von
lautem Gerede beeindrucken lassen wir
werden Entscheidungen treffen die immer
so abgewogen sind dass sie durch ihre
Einbindung in die Entscheidung unserer
internationalen Partner und Verbündete
auch aus Sicherheitsgründen für
Deutschland und Europa gut vertreten
werden können und nicht im Hinblick auf
ihre Wirkung für die Ukraine
dass es nicht um Kampfflugzeuge geht
habe ich ja sehr früh klargestellt und
macht das auch hier als diskutiert wurde
über Flugverbotszonen über der Ukraine
habe ich wie übrigens auch der
amerikanische Präsident gesagt das
werden wir nicht tun und an dieser
Haltung hat sich gar nichts geändert und
wird sich auch nichts ändern
und
Bodentruppen werden wir in keinem Fall
schicken ich habe gesagt es wird keine
direkte Beteiligung von Nato-Soldaten in
dem Ukraine Krieg geben das ist bisher
nicht der Fall und das wird auch in
Zukunft nicht der Fall sein darauf
können sich alle verlassen das ist von
Anfang an so gesagt worden nicht nur von
mir sondern auch vom amerikanischen
Präsidenten und zusammen sollte das ja
wohl ein gewichtiges Wort sein
möchten Sie noch eine Nachfrage stellen
oder okay dann gehe ich weiter in der
Liste vor nächste Frage stellt aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion DR Matthias Mittelberg
Präsidentin herzlichen Dank Herr
Bundeskanzler Themenwechsel wir wollen
uns mit einer Frage befassen die die
Glaubwürdigkeit des Bundeskanzlers
anbetrifft und da konkret den Fall
Warburg Bank der Finanzausschuss des
Bundestages hat einvernehmlich ziemlich
einvernehmlich jetzt ein Protokoll
freigegeben offengelegt das vorher unter
geheimverschluss war dieses Protokoll
gibt eine Aussage wieder die sie gemacht
haben vor dem Finanzausschuss im Jahr
2020 und es betrifft die Konstellation
Warburg sie haben damals sich konkret an
ein Treffen mit dem warburg-chef
olearius im November 2017 erinnern
können
sie haben dieses Treffen bestätigt sie
haben auch bestätigt ausdrücklich dass
ihnen keine Vorbereitung für dieses
Treffen vorgelegen habe und sie haben
weiter bestätigt dass es um die Themen
Sachstand bei Finanzbehörde und
Staatsanwaltschaft gegangen sei ich
frage Sie Herr Bundeskanzler welche
Erinnerung haben sie heute an dieses
konkrete Gespräch mit Herrn olearius und
an die drei weiteren Gespräche die sie
mit Herrn olearius in dieser
Angelegenheit in diesem Zeitraum geführt
haben schönen Dank für Ihre Frage ich
will ehrlicherweise sagen dass jetzt ja
schon sehr viel dazu gefragt worden ist
und auch sehr viele Antworten geben
konnte dass viele Institutionen und
Behörden auch mit all diesen Fragen
beschäftigt worden sind und das Ergebnis
ist immer das gleiche der Vorwurf das
ist eine Beeinflussung durch die
Regierung in Hamburg gegeben habe hat
sich nicht erhärtet und zwar aus einem
ganz einfachen Grund weil da nichts dran
ist
und ein Unterschied zwischen den
verschiedenen Aussagen kann nicht nur
ich nicht sondern auch sonst kaum jemand
ausmachen deshalb habe ich übrigens auch
sehr gerne dafür Veröffentlichung also
das Einvernehmen mit der
Veröffentlichung dieses Protokolls
erklärt
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen vielen
Dank Herr Bundeskanzler dass sie diese
Frage jetzt konkret gar nicht
beantwortet haben
aber gut ich fahre dann mal
folgendermaßen fort wir haben
festgestellt sie haben vier Gespräche in
dem relevanten Zeitraum innerhalb von 15
Monaten vier Gespräche mit Herrn
olearius geführt dreimal Gespräch in
denen sie sich unmittelbar begegnet sind
etwa jeweils eine Stunde in ihrem
Amtszimmer damals als Hamburger
Bürgermeister dann haben sie von sich
aus noch einmal Herrn olearius hinterher
telefoniert um ihn mitzuteilen dass er
seine Unterlagen bitte an Herrn Schenker
weitergeben müssen sie haben eben gesagt
sie wollten keinen Einfluss nehmen das
finde ich sehr nachvollziehbar wir
fragen uns doch dann aber alle wenn man
gar keinen Einfluss nehmen will dann
trifft man sich vielleicht einmal mit
jemand oder ruft ihn einmal an dann sagt
man ihm tut mir leid ich kann da keinen
Einfluss nehmen habe bitte Verständnis
dafür dann trinkt man vielleicht noch
einen Kaffee zusammen und geht kein
auseinander warum können Sie uns das
erklären haben sie sich dreimal mit
Herrn olearius in dieser Angelegenheit
getroffen in dieser Angelegenheit mit
ihm gesprochen warum haben sie ihm dann
noch hinterher telefoniert und haben ihm
die Empfehlung gegeben er möge seine
Unterlagen an Herrn schenscher schicken
der sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht
einmischen wollte in dieser
Angelegenheit warum dann diese vier
Gespräche wenn sie sich gar nicht
einmischen wollten schönen Dank für Ihre
Frage vor allem weil die schon
tausendmal beantwortet worden sind und
im Wesentlichen sich ja alle ihre
Erkenntnisse aus Protokollen
tagebucheintragung von dem genannten
Banker
Speisen ich habe alles dazu gesagt und
will das noch mal sagen mit
verdachtsfragen die etwas suggerieren
sollte man sowieso vorsichtig sein aber
wenn man nachdem sich alles mehrfach als
heiße Luft erwiesen hat immer noch
weitermacht sollte man den Zeitpunkt
finden wo man damit mal aufhört alles
hat sich nicht erwiesen
sie dürfen noch eine weitere Nachfrage
stellen
frau Präsidentin Herr Bundeskanzler
bei cum-ex haben kriminelle den
Steuerzahler um Milliarden Euro betrogen
insofern geht sie nicht um eine
Kleinigkeit und sie wussten Herr
Bundeskanzler das kommen Ex illegal ist
sind nicht grundsätzliche Zweifel an
ihrer Amtsführung angebracht denn sie
treffen sich persönlich mehrfach mit
einer Person von der sie wissen dass
gegen sie wegen schwerer
Steuerhinterziehung ermittelt wird und
wieso haben sie diese persönlichen
Treffen überhaupt ermöglicht in ihrem
Amtszimmer
stundenlang teilweise unter vier Augen
und wieso haben sie keine Vermerke dazu
angefertigt dadurch entziehen sie
regierungshandel natürlich auch der
parlamentarischen Kontrolle
ich will ganz gerne noch mal wiederholen
was ich eben gesagt habe nach so vielen
Jahren so vielen Untersuchungen so
vielen Befragungen so vielen Fakten die
zur Tage getreten sind so vielen Tage
auch Einträgen die immer die gleiche
Auskünfte grundlage sind für alle Ihre
Fragen ist mal Schluss mit Verdacht
äußern der keine Erhärtung gefunden hat
es gibt für das was sie in simulieren
keinen einzigen Beweis das ist schon 100
mal festgestellt worden es steht ihm
frei dass noch 200 Jahre vorzusetzen
wenn sie dazu in der Lage sind aber es
macht keinen Sinn
nächste Frage aus der Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Katrin Uhlig
herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler im Herbst
haben sie eine richtlinie-entscheidung
getroffen darin waren zwei
Gesetzentwürfe enthalten die den
Parlament bereits zugeleitet wurden und
ein ambitioniertes
Energieeffizienzgesetz wurde angekündigt
wann ist geplant dieses
Energieeffizienzgesetz im Kabinett zu
beraten bzw wann können wir als
Parlament damit rechnen dass uns dieser
Entwurf zugeleitet wird schönen Dank für
die Frage bald
mir persönlich ist auch wichtig dass wir
dazu einem guten Ergebnis kommen dafür
fühle ich mich persönlich verpflichtet
und die Arbeit zwischen den beteiligten
Ressorts ist im Gange sehr intensiv
sogar ich glaube auch dass wir da bald
gute Ergebnisse erzielen werden
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
Dankeschön teilen Sie die Einschätzung
das Energieeffizienz ein zentraler Punkt
ist für die Versorgungssicherheit den
Klimaschutz und die Energiewende
ganz unbedingt das haben wir jetzt
gesehen in der letzten Jahr mit den
Gesetzen die wir zum Beispiel möglich
gemacht haben zu einem unbürokratischen
fühl Switch für viele Unternehmen ist es
ja in kürzester Zeit gelungen die
Abhängigkeit von Gast zu reduzieren und
manche haben dabei nicht nur
zurückgegriffen auf frühere Technologien
die noch im Haus waren sondern auch neue
eingesetzt ein guter Fortschritt und das
gleiche gilt für viele viele andere
Maßnahmen die Unternehmen ergriffen
haben aus vielen Gesprächen weiß ich
auch dass manche sich wenn sie sich mal
ans Thema ran gemacht haben gewundert
haben über welches Ausmaß an Einsparung
sie bisher nicht welches Ausmaße
einsparen sie nicht ausgenutzt haben und
deshalb glaube ich brauchen wir als
Gesellschaft da richtig einen ganz
großen Reifen der Sache dass es
hochwirtschaftlich hoch effizient und
deshalb ist dieser Gedanke einer den die
ganze Bundesregierung teilt
[Applaus]
nächste Frage stellt aus der
afd-fraktion DR Bernd Baumann
der Bundeskanzler
viele Migranten in Deutschland
integrieren sich ja gut aber wir haben
nicht erst seit 2015 eine massive
Zuwanderung aus fremden Kulturkreisen
mit ganz anderen Frauenbildern
männerbildern Vorstellungen von Staat
und Gesellschaft
Migrationsforscher wie der
oxford-professor Collier sprechen von
deutlichen kulturdifferenzen das zeigt
sich nicht nur bei schrecklichen
Eskalation in Silvester Nächten
Präsident macron spricht deshalb nicht
von Parallelgesellschaften sondern von
kulturellen gegengesellschaften und das
alles passiert nicht nur in Berlin oder
Köln oder Duisburg überall in Europa
brennen immer wieder stattviertel ob in
Paris oder Marseille in London oder
Birmingham Amsterdam oder Rotterdam
Stockholm oder Koppenhagen das in die
Wiege um kann ja immer auch anders sein
aber es sind immer die gleichen
Migrantengruppen die gleichen
Herkunftsgebiete die gleichen
Integrationsprobleme die so verursacht
werden Herr Bundeskanzler ich frage sie
gibt es aus ihrer Sicht auch ethnisch
kulturelle Differenzen die einer
erfolgreichen Integration im Wege stehen
können
schönen Dank
nein nicht schönen Dank für Ihre Frage
ich will ihre Frage gerne beantworten
danke
Ihre Frage beinhaltet eine ganze Reihe
von Unterstellungen wo man gar nicht
weiß wo man jetzt anfangen soll um ihn
zu widersprechen deshalb will ich ganz
klar sagen aus meiner Sicht ist es so
dass die Demokratie und die offene
pluralistische Gesellschaft davon lebt
dass wir uns als Individuen betrachten
und begegnen dass wir von allen
verlangen dass sie sich an die Gesetze
halten und darauf bestehen dass sie auch
eingehalten werden und dass wir aber
nicht mit Pauschalurteilen von
Gruppenarbeiten wenn es darum geht uns
ganz konkret zu verhalten und zu den
konkreten Verhaltensweisen gehört dass
wir eine offene Gesellschaft sind dass
wir auch Unterschiede akzeptieren aber
keine Unterschiede wenn es darum geht
wie man miteinander umgeht in unserer
Gesellschaft keine Unterschiede wenn es
um die Einhaltung von Recht und Gesetz
geht da ist dann immer die Härte des
Gesetzes gefragt und das ist auch worauf
ich bestehe
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen es war
jetzt keine Antwort auf meine Frage aber
eine weitere Frage der Bundeskanzler es
gibt ein deutsches Staatsvolk das sind
alle Menschen mit deutscher
Staatsbürgerschaft den die gleichen
Rechte und Pflichten zukommen und das ja
auch gut so für ihre Vorgänger von
Adenauer bis Kohl von Brand bis Schmidt
gab es darüber hinaus noch etwas anderes
ein ethnisch kulturelles deutsches Volk
mit einer eigenen geschichtlichen
Identität ich frage den deutschen
Bundeskanzler gibt es aus ihrer Sicht
Jenseits rechtlicher Staatsbürgerschaft
und bloßer Sprachgemeinschaft gibt es
ethnisch kulturell ein deutsches Volk
ich will Ihnen gerne auf die Frage
antworten wir haben ein deutsches Volk
das besteht aus all denjenigen die die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft haben und
die Miteinander in unserer Demokratie
über die Zukunft entscheiden
ich will jetzt mit ihnen kein
geschichtseminar über unsere
Vergangenheit veranstalten wer alles bei
uns lebt und seit wann das der Fall ist
aber ich will den ausdrücklich sagen es
gibt etwas was uns verbindet und das
sind nämlich Überzeugungen die sehr wohl
auch hier in Deutschland gewachsen sind
ja richtigerweise zum Beispiel dass wir
alle gemeinsam egal wo wir geboren sind
oder unsere Eltern und Großeltern gerne
sehr fleißig sind dass wir uns gerne an
die Gesetze halten dass wir unsere
Nachbarn achten und dass wir auch eine
moderne demokratische Gesellschaft sein
wollen die offen ist für das Miteinander
und unterschiedliche Lebensperspektiven
und dafür steht dieses Land und dieses
Volk
nächste Frage stellt Bernd Reuter aus
der FDP-Fraktion
Frau vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundeskanzler sie haben in Ihrem
eingangstatement von mehr Tempo für
unser Land gesprochen und das Thema
planungsbeschleunigung ist ja auch im
Koalitionsvertrag prominent verankert
deswegen möchte ich sie gerne fragen
welche zentralen Maßnahmen wird die
Bundesregierung vorlegen um das Thema
planungsbeschleunigung umzusetzen und
gelten dann diese vorgelegten Maßnahmen
für alle Infrastrukturbereiche
gleichermaßen
schönen Dank für die Frage ich habe sehr
bewusst in meiner eingangsrede gesagt
dass die
neue Geschwindigkeit für unser Land
zentral ist dafür dass wir die große
modernisierungsaufgabe bewältigen die
vor uns liegt und deshalb müssen wir
insgesamt zu einer Beschleunigung kommen
dafür setze ich mich auch ein dass man
das sehen kann dass wir das machen ist
ja eine gute Grundlage für das was jetzt
ansteht im letzten Jahr haben wir mit
denen was den Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien betrifft Frühjahrs und
sommerpaketen die notwendigen
Entscheidungen getroffen wir haben im
letzten Jahr auch weitere
planungsbeschleunigende Maßnahmen auf
den Weg gebracht gerade wird verhandelt
im Deutschen Bundestag eine Reform der
Verwaltungsgerichtsordnung die auch
diese Verfahren beschleunigen soll und
wir sind jetzt dabei konkret dafür Sorge
zu tragen dass wir alle Fortschritte
möglich machen die erforderlich sind um
die von uns selber gewünschte
europäische Richtlinien umzusetzen die
im raumordnungsbereich auch beschleun
Bewegung vorsieht und wir wollen
generell etwa auch wenn es um
Verkehrsleistungen betrifft auch zu
weiteren Beschleunigungen kommen da sind
wir auch hart dran dazu einem
gemeinsamen Ergebnis zu kommen es wird
das große Thema dieser Legislaturperiode
das Deutschland schneller wird und dass
wir den Herausforderungen unserer
Zukunft gewachsen sind
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ja
vielen Dank Herr Bundeskanzler können
Sie in etwa sagen wann die
Bundesregierung dieses Paket vorlegen
wird
wir werden noch viele einzelne Maßnahmen
und deshalb nicht vor allem ein
einzelnes Paket vorlegen viele
einzelmaßen auf den Weg brauchen und
dann bringen und damit auch nicht
aufhören und die Antwort die ich vorhin
einer Kollegin gegeben hat kann ich auch
ihnen geben Alter
nächste Frage stellt aus der Fraktion
DIE LINKE Susanne ferschl
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundeskanzler die Tarifbindung in
Deutschland ist in freien Fall
mittlerweile ist nur noch jeder zweite
Beschäftigte unter dem Schutz eines
Tarifvertrages und eine Richtlinie der
EU schreibt jetzt den nationalen Staaten
vor man in den Maßnahmenplan zu
ergreifen wenn die Tarifbindung unter
80% liegt das ist bei uns der Fall und
ich frag sie stimmen Sie mit mir überein
dass Tarifverträge die Basis für gute
Arbeit in unserem Land sind und welche
Maßnahmen abgesehen von dem bereits
angekündigten bundestarif treuegesetz
wollen sie ergreifen um die Tarifbindung
wieder nach oben zu bekommen zunächst
mal stimme ich sehr mit den überein dass
es wichtig ist dass wir viele
Tarifverträge haben die sind prägend für
das sozialen Modell der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ich bekenne mich sehr
bewusst zu der sozialpartnerschaftlichen
Traditionen unseres Landes und diese
sozialpartnerschaftliche Tradition
beinhaltet natürlich sehr genau auch das
Tarifverträge das Miteinander am
Arbeitsplatz Regeln und ich wünsche mir
dass wir wieder mehr dafür gewinnen mit
verschiedenen Regelungen Gesetzen die
wir auch schon zuletzt durchgesetzt
haben und Perspektiven die wir für die
Zukunft uns vorgenommen haben wollen wir
das unterstützen tarifreue ist einer der
Punkte den sie selbst erwähnt haben
natürlich geht das nicht mit Zwang man
muss dafür sorgen dass Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer sich zusammentun um
Tarifverträge zu verlangen und wir
müssen ihnen dabei helfen dass sie dabei
nicht ungerecht behindert werden und wir
müssen dafür Sorge tragen dass das auch
erfolgreich wird mit den Tarifverträgen
ich bin wie Sie wissen in meinem Beruf
bevor ich Abgeordneter des Deutschen
Bundestages im Jahre 1998 geworden war
arbeitsrechtsanwalt gewesen habe viele
betriebsräte und Gewerkschaften
vertreten auch viele einzelne
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
deshalb ist der Wunsch nach mehr und
leistungsfähigen Tarifverträgen eine der
mir ganz wichtig ist
ich grüße Sie herzlich und Frage möchten
Sie noch eine Nachfrage stellen
bitteschön vielen Dank ich freue mich
auch dass wir so eine große
Übereinstimmung an dem Punkt haben der
Bundeskanzler aber beim der Leiharbeit
wird dieses System ein Stück weit
Adaptionen geführt weil schlechte
Arbeitsbedingungen und Ausbeutung
möglich sind durch eine Öffnung
Öffnungsklauseln die gesetzlich durch
die große Koalition möglich gemacht
worden sind und ich frag sie wann wollen
Sie dieses Schlupfloch schließen damit
auch für Beschäftigte in der Leiharbeit
der Grundsatz gleiche Lohn für gleiche
Arbeit gilt wir haben viele Reformen der
Leiharbeit in der Vergangenheit
vorgenommen genau um die Schlupflöcher
die sie aus vergangener Zeit beschreiben
zu beseitigen und werden uns das auch
weiterhin immer sehr genau angucken aber
das will ich Ihnen schon sagen die
Grundlage für das was an
Handlungsmöglichkeiten besteht sind
immer allgemein akzeptierbare
Tarifverträge und das ist auch die
Grundlage dafür dass wir eine Leiharbeit
mehr Tarifbindung bekommen haben als das
früher der Fall war denn die sind
dadurch sehr gestaltend in dem Bereich
und das ist auch mein Wunsch
die nächste Frage kommt von Kollegen
Timo schebanowski
schisanowski korrekt herzlichen Dank
Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrter
Bundeskanzler die Bundesregierung hat
sich richtigerweise ja zum Ziel gesetzt
Deutschland umfassend zu modernisieren
damit wir auch in 20 in 30 Jahren
erfolgreich sind und
entscheidender Faktor ist ja eine unsere
intakte öffentliche Infrastruktur auch
der Zukunft und zum Jahresauftakt hat
sich deshalb ja auch fallen allen voran
die SPD für ein starkes Comeback eine
aktiven Infrastrukturpolitik für das 21
Jahrhundert ausgesprochen und deshalb in
diesem Zusammenhang meine Frage welche
Strategie und welche Maßnahmen für
Deutschland
Infrastrukturpolitik gedenkt die
Bundesregierung zu ergreifen
zunächst mal geht es darum dass wir wenn
es um öffentliche Infrastruktur geht die
Finanzmittel bereitstellen das haben wir
im großen Umfang getan und das wird auch
weiter trotz der großen Herausforderung
vor denen wir stehen der Fall sein und
das zweite ist dass wir die rechtlichen
Rahmenbedingungen über die wir eben
schon gesprochen haben so verbessern
dass das Geld auch ausgegeben werden
kann und wir vorankommen mit den
Planungen und den Investitionen die in
diesem Bereich notwendig sind ein Teil
der Infrastruktur ist privat das wissen
wir auch
etwa wenn es unser Stromnetz geht oder
das gastnetz oder verschiedene andere
Netze die für uns eine Rolle spielen
Telekommunikation etwa und da müssen wir
durch richtige Gesetze dafür Sorge
tragen dass das auch eine erstklassige
Versorgung wird ich glaube dass die
vielen
weißen Flecken im Bereich des Mobilfunks
zum Beispiel nicht akzeptabel sind und
auch wenn es private anwenderbieter sind
müssen sie Deutschland gut versorgen das
ist mit der privaten Investition in
dieser Frage auch als Verpflichtung
verbunden
Nachfrage stellen bitte sehen
ja besten Dank mein Kollege von der FDP
ist bereits auf die
planungsbeschleunigung eingegangen und
wir alle wissen dass wir für eine
erfolgreiche Infrastrukturpolitik der
Zukunft und die planungsbeschleunigung
insbesondere ein gutes Zusammenspiel
brauchen zwischen Kommunen Ländern und
dem Mond und dem Bund und deshalb meine
Nachfrage wie die gedenken Sie dieses
Zusammenspiel dieses Zusammenwirken der
Ebenen zu befördern
indem man sich unter hakt das wird nicht
anders gehen können indem wir zur
Verfügung stellen was wir an Fähigkeiten
haben ein Bereich der Planung haben wir
übernommen was die Bundesfernstraßen
betrifft aber es wird insgesamt um enge
Kooperationen gehen und dass das ein
alltägliche Praxis wird wir sind
jedenfalls dazu bereit
[Applaus]
der Kollege Lucas stellt jetzt die
nächste Frage bitte schön
frau Präsidentin der Bundeskanzler
vielen Dank ich möchte eine Frage zur
Wohnungsbaupolitik stellen die Ampel hat
sich in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
vorgenommen 400.000 Wohnungen im Jahr zu
bauen das sind 1,6 Millionen Wohnungen
in der Legislaturperiode das ist auch
wichtig und auch notwendig weil wir
sehen dass gerade in den großen Städten
die Schlangen bei den
Wohnungsbesichtigungen über länger
werden die Mieten steigen es fehlt eine
Bezahlbarkeit des Bodens deswegen
brauchen wir diesen Neubau dann stellen
wir aber fest und das sagen alle
Experten dass dieses Ziel nicht einmal
zur Hälfte erfüllt werden wird alle
sagen das zeigen die Schlagzeilen der
letzten Tage es werden wahrscheinlich
nicht 400.000 Wohnungen gebaut werden
sondern einen letzten Jahr
wahrscheinlich nur 280 in diesem Jahr
nur 250 und so weiter also es werden
deutlich weniger Wohnung gebaut werden
was sagen Sie jetzt diesen Menschen die
in den Schlangen bei den
Wohnungsbesichtigungen stehen und am
Ende keine bezahlbare Wohnung haben
wieso ihre bauministerin und ihre
Bundesregierung dieses so wichtige Ziel
für unser Land nicht erreicht schönen
Dank für Ihre Frage und ich will ihnen
erstmal bestätigen dass das ein
zentrales Ziel ist dass wir
kontinuierlich die Bauleistungen in
Deutschland nach oben treiben damit dann
regelmäßig 400.000 Wohnungen gebaut
werden dass wir das können kann man
daran sehen dass wenn man
ich glaube ganz genaue verhaften sich
man nicht auf die Zahl aber West und Ost
zusammenrechnet 1972 wer etwa 800.000
Wohnungen gebaut haben ist also keine
unerfüllbare Aufgabe aber das bedeutet
dass die Unternehmen dass diejenigen die
investieren und dass sie die stetige
Gemeinden alle anderen diese Perspektive
auch so im Blick haben dass sie
langfristige Investitionen zur
Ausweitung ihrer Kapazitäten treffen
damit diese Zielsetzung auch erfüllt
werden können und das versuchen wir auch
zu unterstützen mit dem Bündnis für das
Wohnen und den Verabredungen die dort
getroffen worden sind wo sehr sehr viele
ganz im Einzelnen beschriebene
Beschwernisse des Bauens abgebaut werden
und daran arbeiten wir jetzt die alle
einen nach dem anderen in aus dem Tempo
zu beseitigen gleichzeitig brauchen wir
eine Vereinheitlichung wenn wir seriell
bauen wollen was übrigens nicht Platte
heißt wie es von einigen immer behauptet
wird aber wenn wir seriell bauen wollen
also die Grundstruktur öfter mal als die
gleiche haben dann bedeutet das auch
dass man mit dem einmal irgendwo in
Deutschland genehmigten
Haus auch vielleicht anderswo noch
realisieren kann ob man als Eckhaus als
Mittelhaus oder als als als einzelnes
Objekt als Turmhaus wenn es um
mehrfamilienwohnungen geht und diesen
Fortschritt den müssen wir unbedingt
erreichen weil das eine Verbesserung
bedeutet für viele Unternehmen die sich
dann darauf verlassen können dass sie
mit der Grundstruktur die sich schon mal
genehmigt bekommen haben auch an anderen
Stellen in Deutschland bauen können und
meinen Eindruck ist das würde auch dazu
führen dass es erhebliche
Kostenreduktionen gibt in einer
erheblicher Teil der Kosten des
Wohnungsbau sind mit dem
Planungsunternehmen Prozessen verknüpft
meine Nachfrage bitteschön
der Bundeskanzler sie haben zwei
wichtige Punkte angesprochen zum einen
die Verlässlichkeit von
Förderbedingungen damit die
Bauwirtschaft Kapazitäten aufbauen kann
zum anderen das Bündnis für bezahlbaren
Wohnraum wir erklären sich dann aber
dass die Wohnungswirtschaft also die
Unternehmen die am Ende die Wohnung
schaffen müssen sagen dass sie ihre
Projekte jetzt deswegen stornieren
müssen weil diese Bundesregierung die
Förderung für den Neubau radikal gekappt
hat zusammengestrichen hat dass die
Wirtschaftlichkeit der Projekte nicht
mehr gegeben ist und deswegen nicht mehr
bezahlbar gebaut werden kann und wieso
erklären sie sich wenn das von ihnen so
hoch gelobte Bündnisse bezahlbaren
Wohnraum nur sechs Wochen nachdem sie
mit der bauministerin die Ergebnisse
präsentiert haben ist ein alarmierenden
Weckruf auf der Immobilienwirtschaft
gegeben hat man brauche jetzt einen
neuen entschieden den politischen
Kraftakt weil das bisherige nicht
ausreicht wie erklären sich das zunächst
haben wir einen großen Kraftwerk
vorgenommen indem wir die Mittel für den
geförderten Wohnungsbau erheblich
ausgeweitet haben das ist auch ganz ganz
zentral weil dann bezahlbare Wohnung auf
dem Wohnungsmarkt neu entstehen und
vielleicht darf ich Ihnen diese
statistische Besonderheit sagen in
manchen Städten in Deutschland wenn man
da genauer hinschaut sind die Hälfte der
Mietwohnung die es gibt irgendwann mal
als geförderte Wohnung entstanden
zwischen
1919 und heute und das ist ein Hinweis
darauf dass es da eine lange Tradition
des geförderten Wohnungsbaus für
bezahlbare Wohnungen gibt und dass das
bis heute die Struktur unserer Städte
und die Bezahlbarkeit des
wohnraumangebotes prägt eine gute Sache
also und auch gut dass wir das neu
ausgeweitet haben bei den förderregimen
die wir bisher hatten waren sehr viele
die am Ende unterschiedslos auch die
Häuser und Wohnungen gefördert haben von
Leuten die Kraft ihrer Finanzen auch
ohne die Förderung den Wohnungsbau
errichtet hätten und entweder sehr sehr
teure Mieten die nur für einige zahlbar
sind akzeptiert hätten oder aber eben
sehr hohe Preise für den Erwerb eine
Eigentumswohnung oder eines Einfamilien
zum Beispiel und deshalb ist es schon
richtig die Fokussierung darauf zu
nehmen dann aber mit der Unterstützung
im Bereich der Programme die die KfW auf
den Weg bringt etwas dafür zu tun dass
Wohnungsbau vorangebracht werden kann
auch außerhalb des sozialen Wohnungsbaus
und das auch Familien nicht alleine
gelassen werden das ist das vielleicht
ist das jetzt ganz wichtig dass die
fehlorientierung jetzt konzentriert
worden ist auf das was am Ende zu einer
Entlastung auf dem Wohnungsmarkt
beiträgt und ich hoffe dass das Tempo
dann auch hinterher zieht jetzt werden
einige ihre Projekte umplanen müssen und
dann wird es vielleicht nicht
9000 12000 € pro Quadratmeter
Eigentumswohnung sondern eine bezahlbare
Wohnung das wäre jetzt aber für
Deutschland insgesamt auch kein so
großes Problem
möchten Sie einen weiteren Nachfrage
stellen das ist nicht der Fall dann ist
die nächste Frage
das war die regierungsbefragung von
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz wir gehen ein
klein wenig früher raus denn jetzt dreht
es sich ja wieder um einige andere
Themen wir wollen aber mit euch jetzt
noch mal ganz klar in dieser Sendung
analysieren
analysieren und Fragen stellen eure
Fragen stellen über die
Panzerlieferungen die beschlossen worden
sind die Deutschen panzernlieferungen in
die Ukraine der Bundeskanzler hat sich
da vielen Fragen gestellt hat sich dazu
geäußert verteidigte sein ab wegen den
Kurs nannte das mit voller Absicht dass
da also auf Abstimmung gewartet wurde er
sagte außerdem Zitat Deutschland sei
immer vorne wenn es darum geht die
Ukraine zu unterstützen sprach davon
dass die enge Kooperation und Abstimmung
mit anderen Bündnispartnern ist immer
das Prinzip und außerdem betonte er auch
noch ein weiteres Prinzip und zwar
Eskalation zwischen NATO und Russland
verhindern dass in einer Kürze jetzt
aber mit viel Zeit also eure Fragen und
wer sich noch mehr für das Thema
interessiert heute Abend bei uns RTF im
Fernsehen ein was nun Herr Scholz mit
anneganinek und Bettina Schausten um
19.25 und um 19:55 Uhr ein ZDF Spezial
wir können jetzt widersprechen mit
Albrecht von Lucke unserem
Politikwissenschaftler wir hatten vorhin
nur kurz das Vergnügen und sehen uns
jetzt wieder schönen guten Tag Herr Luca
ich möchte auch direkt mit unseren User
fragen viele sind ja zusammengekommen
und Kommentaren aus dem Stream
einsteigen ist wir haben auch aufgehört
in unserem Gespräch mit natürlich auch
sorgen die geäußert worden sind und das
habe ich auch bei uns im Stream gesehen
z.B Michael Zander schrieb bei Facebook
ich habe Angst vor einem Krieg in dem
wir reingezogen werden und ich habe
Angst um meine Kinder also Sorge und
Angst die auch einige Menschen jetzt
äußern ob der panzerlieferung für die
Ukraine wenngleich die natürlich auch im
Vorfeld von einigen vielen anderen
gefordert waren die Frage an Sie Herr
Lucke also wer Sprachen ja über die
Sorge vor Eskalation des Krieges was
haben Sie in den Antworten des
Bundeskanzlers der mir auch mitgehört
was haben sie gehört was er den Menschen
entgegnet hat die diese Sorgen äußern
der Kanzler hat es geschafft und das ist
das eigentlich bemerkenswerte dieser
immer übrigens schwierigen Fragestunde
dieses Format ist ausgesprochen
schwierig wir haben das gemerkt die
Opposition ist kaum in der Lage längere
Ausführung zu machen eine Routinier wie
Olaf Scholz kann diese Fragen eigentlich
ziemlich cool abkochen und das in einem
entscheidenden und aus einem
entscheidenden Grund er hat ja mit
dieser Entscheidung die Amerikaner
einzubinden genau dem worauf auch Ihre
Frage abstellt worauf ihre Frage
abstellt den Wind aus den Segeln
genommen die ganz große Angst und das
spiegelt sich auch in Teilen der
Bevölkerung eine Angst übrigens die Olaf
Scholz nicht davor nicht unbedingt
kleiner gemacht hat denn er hat sich ja
nie sehr klar erklärt was seine
Strategien in diesem Krieg sind er hat
diese Angst aber jetzt reduziert und das
ist das sicherlich entscheidende was er
geschafft hat dadurch dass er die
Amerikaner ins Boot geholt hat das war
auch hier wieder der entscheidende Punkt
auf den er abgestellt hat manchmal
überschäumt die ist Olaf Scholz
Eigenheit ist mit Selbstlob denn es kann
natürlich nicht die Rede davon sein dass
man immer nur gemeinsam gehandelt habe
lange war Deutschland getrieben die
Europäer hätten zum Teil weit früher
handeln wollen aber was Scholz für sich
reklamiert das war die durchgängige
Botschaft die Menschen sind bei mir gut
aufgehoben das hat er am Ende seiner
Ausführung zum Krieg noch mal
ausdrücklich gesagt weil ich die Angst
sehe und deshalb dezidiert nie ohne die
Amerikaner im Alleingang Vorgehen würde
und das ist natürlich in der Tat ein
starkes Argument denn so ist deutlicher
geworden Russland muss wissen wenn es
sich mit Deutschland anlegt oder auch
mit einem anderen europäischen Staat die
Amerikaner sind an der europäischen
Seite das ist noch einmal dadurch klarer
geworden und so versucht Urlaub Scholz
die Angst im Lande zu bekämpfen ich habe
zwei sehr unterschiedliche Positionen
auch bei uns im Stream gesehen einmal
schrieb jemand schicken sie besser 100
Diplomaten für Verhandlungen und der
gewinnen ein anderer User schrieb
Diplomatie wurde vor dem Angriffskrieg
auf die Ukraine genug ausprobiert aber
alle Politiker sind an der
Verweigerungshaltung eines Diktators
Putin abgeprallt für diplomatische
Lösung braucht es immer mindestens zwei
die aufeinander zugehen was sagen sie
dazu so zwei gegensätzlichen Meinungen
vollkommen in Ordnung dass es die
natürlich gibt aber Verhandlungen
Diplomaten Diplomatie überhaupt noch
möglich oder eben wie hier die
dirk-winen schreibt das ist gar nicht
mehr möglich
nein das ist es nicht denn es wird am
Ende das muss man sich immer wieder
bewusst machen zu einem hoffentlich ja
vielleicht sogar Friedensvertrag kommen
und nicht nur zu einer Einfrierung einer
verteilen Situation aber eines bleibt
leider auch richtig und festzustellen
jetzt einfach 100 Diplomaten in die Welt
zu schicken wird bei einem
imperialistischen revisionistischen
Potentaten die Putin gar nichts
anrichten man muss leider und das ist ja
die Erkenntnis des letzten Jahres
Diplomatie immer gemeinsam mit
militärischer Intervention zusammen
denken nur um es auf den Punkt zu
bringen wenn die Ukraine stark genug ist
dass sie die weitere Eroberung der
Russen zurückschlagen kann und
vielleicht seiner ihrerseits ein Stück
des Landes zurückerobern kann nur so
wird sie Putin möglicherweise eines
Tages die Bereitschaft
zufriedensverhandlungen abtrotzen das
kann aber dramatischerweise noch ein
langer Weg sein denn wir sehen ja gerade
und das ist die gegenwärtige Lage das
Russland eine gewaltige mobilemmachung
in Gang gesetzt hat das ist gewaltige
Truppen aber auch Menschen wieder in die
Ukraine schickt und Putin bekanntlich
bereit ist Sie alle regelrecht zu
verheizen die Menschen die ihm
offensichtlich und einem Machthaber oder
einem Kriegsherrn wie trikotin noch viel
weniger etwas wert sind das zeigt
solange die Ukraine nicht ertüchtigt
wird
dem zu wehren sich dem zu widersetzen
werden alle diplomatischen ersuchungen
ersuchen keinen Erfolg haben am Ende
kann es nur so sein dass Putin zu der
Einsicht kommt er kommt auf
militärischem Wege nicht weiter nur dann
wird der Punkt erreicht sein dass man
Diplomatie gemeinsam tätigen kann also
es muss Diplomatie immer leider
gemeinsam mit einer militärischen
Ertüchtigung der Ukraine gedacht werden
sagt Albrecht von Luca und
Politikwissenschaftler heute bei uns in
der Sendung vielen Dank
ich danke Ihnen
und weitere Reaktionen nach der
regierungsbefragung von Kanzler Olaf
Scholz können wir nun besprechen mit
meiner Kollegin mit Korrespondentin
Andrea Maurer sie ist live vor Ort und
auch nicht alleine denn Andrea du hast
ja auch einen Gast dazu geholt und wir
können jetzt noch mal gemeinsam sprechen
und eine nachleser haben über diese
regierungsbefragung Andrea ich schalte
jetzt auch direkt zu dir rüber dass du
für uns noch mal einschätzen kannst was
wir da gerade gehört haben
ja genau also bei mir ist die
Vorsitzende des Verteidigungsausschusses
Maria Zimmermann hallo Frau Zimmermann
danke dass Sie sich die Zeit nehmen sie
gelten ja als diejenige die Druck
gemacht hat auf den Kanzler auch dass er
sich endlich mal erklärt jetzt hat er
sich heute erklärt war das für sie
ausreichend als Erklärung dir da
geliefert hat also es geht jetzt nicht
um die findlichkeiten von Herrn Scholz
oder von Frau Zimmermann es geht darum
dass die Ukraine seit 11 Monaten ein
Jahres schon Krieg erleben muss dass sie
Hilfe braucht dass sie um Panzer gebeten
hat wir haben die Diskussion geführt
jetzt kommt der Schützenpanzer in
Kombination mit dem kampfanze und das
ist für die Menschen die so fürchterlich
unter diesem Krieg leiden in der Ukraine
ein guter Tag dass diese Entscheidung
gefällt worden ist der Kanzler hat die
heute auch klar gemacht dass er sein
eigenes Tempo hat und seine eigenen
Prinzipien an die sich wohl die anderen
halten müssen der Kollege von der Union
hat gesagt das ist ein Flurschaden
entstanden also es gab ja tatsächlich
auch in der Koalition Streit sehen Sie
diesen Flurschaden auf dem Weg zu der
Entscheidung jetzt auch
also dass das nicht ganz unproblematisch
war ich glaube ich habe mich dazu sehr
laut und deutlich geäußert jetzt geht es
aber darum dass es jetzt ganz praktisch
in die Hand genommen werden muss die
Entscheidung Leopard 2 zu liefern
bedeutet ja nicht dass man einfach
damals so ein Panzer rüber fährt es muss
organisiert werden die ukrainischen
Soldaten müssen ausgebildet werden und
zwar parallel ein Teil
animarderanteil am Leopard die Logistik
muss stimmen das sind ja alles
Herausforderungen die werden jetzt
angegangen und ich gehöre grundsätzlich
zu denen die nach vorne gucken dorthin
wo man fahren empfehle ich Events gehen
dorthin zu gucken wo man hin will und
jetzt wollen wir dass die Ukraine
schnellstmöglich diese Waffensysteme
bekommt und die Stellungen die eben
brutal umkämpft sind und wo ist kein vor
und zurückgibt dass die Ukraine die
Chance bekommen mit modernem Gerät die
Russen zurückzudrängen sie sind ja heute
im Verteidigungsausschuss auch noch mal
informiert worden Herr Pistorius war
auch vor Ort es geht ja jetzt auch so
ein bisschen um die Interpretation warum
das so lange gedauert hat also war der
Kanzler erfolgreich in dem er es
hinausgezögert hat hat er dadurch die
Amerikaner dazu gebracht auch apprams zu
liefern diese internationale
panzerallianz zu schmieden sehen Sie ihn
denn da so erfolgreich
ach wissen Sie wir können jetzt
interpretieren ich habe die Bestätigung
von den Vereinigten Staaten noch nicht
das war auch heute überhaupt kein Thema
im Verteidigungsausschuss wir haben uns
in der geheimersitzung wieder mit der
Ukraine beschäftigt dann was sehr
erfreulich kam war dass der neue
Verteidigungsminister kam der sehr
dezidiert war sehr deutlich auch die
Aufgabe der Bundeswehr sah das muss ich
sagen fanden wir alle sehr spannend das
zwei Prozent Ziel zu erhalten die
Bundeswehr zu modernisieren das ist ja
das wofür die Ampel auch angetreten ist
und da ist natürlich auch aufgrund des
Drucks des Krieges der natürlich den
Scheinwerfer auch auf anderes gelenkt
hat vieles liegen geblieben und da muss
ich sagen da macht der
Verteidigungsminister ein sehr klaren
Eindruck da hat er uns an seiner Seite
diese Reform jetzt anzugehen das ist
unglaublich wichtig weil wir geben ja
jetzt auch sehr viel Material ab und die
Sorge der Bundeswehr ist ja zu recht
kommt das Material denn wieder zurück
und das ist leider in den letzten
Monaten hat das Verteidigungsministerium
nichts bestellt was abgegeben wurde das
ist die erste Aufgabe damit nicht
Deutschland etwas Bündnis nachher ein
Problem bekommt weil die wichtigsten
Dinge abgegeben worden sind und da bin
ich äußerst positiv dass wir da in die
richtige Richtung laufen und zwar
gemeinsam es gibt ja jetzt eine Frage
die im Raum steht die auch heute
gestellt wurde auch von der Linken
gestellt wird wo soll das alles enden
also Herr Melnik hat ja Kampfflugzeuge
ins Gespräch gebracht sie haben selber
deutlich gesagt das sehen sie nicht aber
wie muss jetzt diese Debatte vielleicht
dann auch noch mal eingefangen werden
weil nach den Malern kam sofort Leos
oder kommen jetzt Leos können Sie das
verstehen dass eben diese Frage jetzt im
Raum steht wo soll das denn
ja ich kann das irgendwo verstehen da
sitzen Menschen seit fast einem Jahr im
Keller werden Nachbarn ermordet Frauen
vergewaltigt das ist brutalste Gewalt
und wir haben natürlich die wir hier in
in Deutschland sind die dieser Gefahr
nicht ausgesetzt sind haben natürlich
gut reden sozusagen uns Zeit zu lassen
das hat die Ukraine nicht ich glaube
trotzdem dieser Aufbruch jetzt das
Deutschland Leopard 2 ist der modernste
Kampfpanzer der Welt bereit ist
abzugeben gemeinsam in der
internationalen Gemeinschaft das ist ein
wirklich großer großer Schritt und damit
müssen wir uns jetzt beschäftigen und
was wir auch unbedingt brauchen ist eine
Strategie nämlich was könnte passieren
im März im April wenn das Wetter sich
ändert wenn es wieder wärmer wird wenn
der Boden nicht mehr gefroren sondern
schlammig ist das heißt im militärischen
brauchen Sie ein Szenario und dann
müssen Sie die Lage anpassen das ist
viel wichtiger als jetzt nach dem Motto
jetzt kommt der leopard-diskussion
beendet hatten da dran jetzt machen wir
ein nächstes fast auf so kann das nicht
funktionieren sondern wir müssen uns mit
der Ukraine und mit den Partnern muss
überlegt werden was könnte passieren
wenn es nicht kommt umso besser das
könnte passieren und wie kann die
Antwort des Westens aussehen und dieser
Streit der jetzt in der Koalition in den
letzten Tagen tatsächlich zu spüren war
glauben sie der ist jetzt wirklich
einfach bereinigt weil da sind ja schon
deutliche Differenzen auch klar
also ich bin in die Politik gegangen um
für Ziele zu um Ziele zu ringen ich bin
relativ unempfindlich was mich betrifft
ich ertrage das da gibt es vielleicht
den eine oder anderen der ist da
sensibler aber es geht wirklich nicht um
Befindlichkeiten wir sind hier nicht in
der Kita meiner Enkeltochter sondern wir
sind im Deutschen Bundestag wir müssen
auch in einer Regierung Ringen streiten
im guten Sinne was der beste Weg ist
dafür werden wir gewählt das erwarten
die Menschen und deswegen bin ich
persönlich sehr sehr zuversichtlich dass
wir gut zusammenarbeiten und dass wir
auch wieder diskutieren werden aber wer
das nicht kann wer nicht
die Hitze abkant darf nicht in die Küche
gehen vielen Dank Frau Zimmermann an
dieser Stelle und damit zurück ins
Studio Andrea Maurer war das im Gespräch
mit Marie Agnes Strack Zimmermann von
der FDP einem Partei die immer wieder im
Vorfeld Olaf Scholz für die zögerliche
Haltung kritisiert hatte eben gerade
angesprochen von Marie Agnes Streck
Zimmermann aber auch ein Thema kommt das
Material auch wieder zu uns zurück und
Bedenken was das natürlich bedeutet wenn
wir Material aus Bundeswehr Beständen
abgeben hatte gestern auch der Chef des
bundeswehrverbands andre Wüstner im
heute journal geäußert wir hören mal
zusammen rein
ich habe ja in den letzten Tagen und
Wochen Monaten zum Ausdruck gebracht
dass wir beispielsweise in den
gepanzerten Kampftruppen der
einsatzbereitschaftslage von 33% haben
das ist zu wenig mit Blick auf diese
jetzt vermutlich 14 Kampfpanzer Leopard
mit den Schützenpanzern aber auch mit
den anderen Systemen wenn wir zunehmend
Probleme haben die Bundeswehr ist nach
wie vor im freien Fall und das erwartet
deswegen erwarte ich schon morgen ein
Umsteuern von der Politik wir müssen
endlich in einer Art Kriegswirtschaft
wir müssen endlich die industriestärken
die Politik muss beantworten wann Sie
unsere Systeme ersetzt sie erinnern sich
Panzer Pizza Raketenwerfer jetzt der
Kampfpanzer wann will man diese Systeme
ersetzen weil es ist eben nicht so wie
einige vermuten das in diesem Jahr diese
Krieg zu Ende gehen wird es wird noch
länger dauern und ich bezweifle dass
Putin mit seinen Aggressionen in den
nächsten Jahren aufhören wird deswegen
will ja auch die NATO ihre
abschreckungsfähigkeit erhöhen und
deswegen hat auch Deutschland einen
entsprechenden Beitrag zugesagt nur
bezweifle ich bei weiteren Abgaben dass
wir diesen Beitrag leisten können werden
über diese Fragen und natürlich auch
noch weitere von euch können wir jetzt
sprechen mit dem ehemaligen Nato-General
mit Egon Rams heute auch wieder bei uns
schön dass Sie da sind hallo
schönen guten Tag wir haben es eben
gehört von Herrn Wüstner erfordert ein
Umsteigen in eine Kriegswirtschaft sehen
sie so etwas ist das überhaupt
realistisch dass das passiert
also der Begriff Kriegswirtschaft ist
vielleicht nicht der richtige und wir
haben dafür auch im Augenblick in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland keine
gesetzlichen Grundlagen
im Kalten Krieg hätte man das anordnen
können nach entsprechenden Zuständen
beispielsweise Spannungsfall und
dergleichen mehr das gibt es heute nicht
mehr von daher gibt es diese Möglichkeit
nicht aber im Kern hat der wüstern mit
seiner Aussage recht die Bundeswehr muss
dieses Material welches sie aus eigenem
Beständen abgegeben hat ersetzt bekommen
wir haben zwei Probleme wir haben in den
truppenstrukturen nicht das Material was
wir überall benötigen und zum zweiten
haben wir das Problem das nehmen dem
fehlenden Material wie auch immer das
Problem haben dass wir keine Reserven
haben wenn wir Reserven hätten wie es
früher mal der Fall war dann wären wir
auch durchaus in der Lage gewesen aus
diesen reservebeständen Waffen abzugeben
das wäre dann mit Blick auf die
Bundeswehr uns doch deutlich leichter
gefallen
dazu passt die Frage von Monika bardell
die bei Youtube wissen möchte wie
schnell bekommt die Ukraine die Panzer
denn jetzt und baut Deutschland dann
auch neue Panzer
also ich sage mal auf diese Frage ich
hoffe dass die Ukraine die Waffen sehr
schnell bekommt es wäre gut gewesen wenn
sie jetzt beispielsweise bei den Kämpfen
die um Solidar und bachmut stattgefunden
haben bzw stattfinden über derartige
Waffensystem auch vor allem Verbund
Panzer und Panzergrenadiere verfrüchtete
das war nicht der Fall von daher wäre es
gut gewesen die Waffensysteme werden da
gewesen aber ich gehe davon aus dass wir
wahrscheinlich über einen Ansatz sage
ich mal so irgendwo zwischen 6 bis 8
Wochen reden ist a die Panzer zur
Verfügung gestellt werden wie die
Besatzung dafür ausgebildet sind C die
Nachschub und Logistikkette aufgebaut
ist um diese Panzer auch entsprechend
versorgen zu können und wir stellen wir
heißt jetzt die westliche Gemeinschaft
nicht nur Deutschland die
keiner auch vor ein Problem nämlich das
im Augenblick richtig übersehe dann
liefern wir vier verschiedene Typen das
heißt wir brauchen viel logistiketten in
einigen Bereichen und das macht die
Sache für die Ukraine nicht einfacher
zum zweiten Teil der Frage ja
ich mache das Fest am Beispiel des
Leopard 2 wir bräuchten nur für unsere
Struktur aktive Struktur bei den
Truppenteilen etwa 330 Kampfpanzer
Leopard 2 wir haben zurzeit etwa 280
oder etwas über 180 wenn wir die 14
abgeben dann haben wir noch uns 270 das
heißt dann fehlen 60 Kampfpanzer Leopard
2 als strukturbedarf von daher ist muss
die Nachproduktion
unverzüglich eingeleitet werden damit
sie die Truppe auch entsprechend wieder
ausrüsten können und damit dann auch
einigen Bereichen den NATO
Verpflichtungen nachkommen können die
wir auf uns genommen haben
beispielsweise in diesem Jahr mit der
very Hybriden des Joints Task Force die
durch Deutschland geführt wird und wo
Deutschland auch Truppenteilen dran
beteiligt ist
wobei wir müssen natürlich auch ganz
klar sagen dass was jetzt versprochen
wurde zunächst von deutscher Seite sind
14 Leopard 2 Panzer über die wir
sprechen da fragt sich unser User Gaus
bei Youtube sind 14 Stück Leopard nicht
zu wenig
die Antwort lautet eindeutig ja also 14
Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 werden den
Kriegsverlauf in der Ukraine nicht
ändern dafür ist einfach zu wenig man
muss man aber nicht nur die deutschen
sehen man muss auch das Angebot der Pole
sehen mit 14 die finden haben mal von 20
gesprochen die Holländer wollen sich
möglicherweise allerdings mit geliebten
Panzern ebenfalls beteiligen so dass ich
sage aber wenn ich das was im Augenblick
bei Leopard 2 auf dem Tisch riecht sagen
würde damit kriegt man einen
Panzerbataillon zusammen also irgendwo
sage ich mal zwischen 40 und 50 Rio 2
und dann müssen wir die Zusage der
Amerikaner sehen das sind leider zur
Zeit die Zahlen sehr schwanken heute
tauchte in einem Bericht kauft die Zahl
50 auf das halte ich im Augenblick für
sehr erstaunlich denn gestern war noch
von 14 spricht also auch eine Kompanie
Gerede dazu kommen die britischen
Challenger und dazu kommt dann noch
möglicherweise die französischen erklärt
so dass man vielleicht in diesem Bereich
ich sag das mal ein dieses panzervation
mit drei Typen zusammenstellen kann das
heißt wir reden über zwei bis
zweieinhalb babylonen die können den
Einzelbereichen nicht sprach vorhin
wachmut an können die eine entsprechende
Wirkung zeigen aber sie werden den
Kriegsverlauf nicht ändern das heißt wir
müssen davon ausgehen dass weitere
Forderungen von Seiten der Ukraine
gestellt werden und der Kanzler hat
vorhin das ist vielleicht ein bisschen
untergegangen in einem kleinen kurzen
Satz bei seiner Erklärung gesagt dass
man dann davon ausgehen müsste dass man
möglicherweise auch Kampfpanzer älterer
Typen liefert und dann steht
möglicherweise wieder der Leopard 1 auf
15 Diskussion der so viel schlechter als
der Leopard 2 nicht ist die ja von
manchen Experten gemacht
was er auch gesagt hat der Kanzler auf
die Frage wo ist die Grenze der
deutschen Unterstützung sagte er es geht
nicht um Kampfflugzeuge also das würde
man nicht entsenden an der Haltung wird
sich Zitat nichts ändern keine
Bodentruppen danach wurde auch gefragt
und eben keine direkte Beteiligung
darauf können sich alle verlassen sagt
in der Kanzler also sie glauben auch
dabei bleibt für immer
also die direkte Beteiligung ist für
mich eine Stelle die ja auch in der NATO
einvernehmlich beschlossen worden ist
einer der Abgeordnete stellt ja vorhin
in der Sendung auch die Frage nach
Bodentruppen das ist ein ein Punkt den
ich schlicht und einfach ausschließe den
muss ich ausschließen einfach aus dem
Grunde weil dann in dem Augenblick die
NATO als Ganzes oder einzelne Staaten
der NATO Kriegsteilnehmer werden und da
wollen wir eigentlich nicht hin wirklich
nicht hin und diese diese Entscheidung
sollte auch in jedem Falle durchgehalten
werden egal wie groß der Druck dabei ist
bei den Flugzeugen sehe ich eine
Alternative also ich würde keine
Flugzeuge stellen und halte das auch
nicht für zweckmäßig sah ich ganz
deutlich da hat es ja auch schon vor
etlicher Zeit ganz zu Anfang oder nach
den ersten Monaten des Krieges die
Diskussion gegeben über die
Flugverbotszone wo ja auch die
nato-straßen einvernehmlich gesagt haben
eine solche Flugverbotszone können und
werden wir nicht einrichten auch diese
Entscheidung sollte so durchgehalten
werden das heißt keine Kampfflugzeuge
das kann man immer möglicherweise
kompensiven kompensieren indem man der
Ukraine noch weitere Flugabwehrsysteme
gibt denn es geht ja um die Frage der
Luft Überlegenheit der russischen Seite
wobei die auch nicht mehr so stark ist
wie sie früher zu Anfang mal war um
diese Luft Überlegenheit abzubauen das
kann man auch mit
Luftverteidigungssystem machen und wenn
man Kenntnisstand richtig ist sind die
Ukraine ja in diesem Spiel mit dem
plug-panzer Gepard mit den
fliegerfäusten aber auch mit mit anderen
ihres Tee SM sehr erfolgreich es werden
weitere Systeme Ihr System werden
geliefert werden da stand eigentlich
damals schon fest das ist aber eine
Frage jetzt der Produktion durch die
entsprechende deutsche Firma und ich
hoffe dass diese Produktion weit
vorangeht da bin ich wieder bei einem
Punkt angesprochen hatte ich nenne das
nicht Kriegswirtschaft aber es wäre gut
gewesen für die deutsche Industrie
sowohl im Blick auf derartige System
aber auch mit Blick auf die Produktion
wenn irgendjemand ich sag das mal
vorsichtig im März April gesagt hätte
Leute schmeißt die Bänder alles muss
losgehen und das gleiche gilt auch für
die Leopard 2 wie viel die Bundeswehr
ersetzt werden müssen nicht nur im
Bundestag auch bei uns im Chat gibt es
immer wieder sorgenvolle stimmen so
schreibt Christian auf Facebook wie
gewohnt gibt es wieder kaum kritische
Stimmen also das bemängelt er zu dem
Thema wenn der Tabubruch erstmal
passiert ist wird sich die
Eskalationsspirale weiterdrehen die
Forderungen werden nicht abreißen und es
kommt zu einem jahrelang festgefahrenen
Stellvertreterkrieg würden sie da
zustimmen ist das auch das wie sie die
Zukunft zeichnen würden
also ich sehe zu dem was jetzt
entschieden worden ist und da sagt ich
ganz vorsichtig auch bei sorgfältigem
nachdenken keiner alternative das hat
frau Zimmermann von ihren Gespräch mit
ihrer Korrespondentin gesagt in der
Ukraine sterben jeden Tag Menschen
Zivilisten und Militärs und das ist für
mich eigentlich ein unerklärliche
Vorstellung oder unerträgliche
Vorstellung wo ich auch ausgesprochen
vorsichtig bin
sehr sorgfältig überlege vor allen
Dingen vor dem Hintergrund was ist das
Kriegsziel Russlands dabei die
Aggression hat stattgefunden um die
Ukraine im Prinzip auszuradieren und
alles in Groß Russland einzufahren das
ist nicht hinnehmbar von den
demokratischen Staaten weil es gegen
alle unsere Grundsätze verstößt
hintergrund dafür sind sich gebrochene
Verträge von Seiten der russischen Seite
oder vielleicht sage ich das sogar
personifiziert bezogen aufhören Putin
Verträge die eigentlich das
Zusammenleben in Europa
zwischen
1975 Helsinki Prozess bis zum Jahre 2000
und vielleicht auch so
2002/2003 verlässlich und gut geregelt
haben dass es alles gebrochen worden
Verträge die in 90er Jahren geschlossen
worden sind von daher muss man
vorsichtig sein ja das Risiko dass
dieser Krieg sich noch lange hinzieht
besteht aber dieses Risiko ist auch
verbunden mit der Aussage von meiner
Seite wenn wir die Ukraine nicht
entsprechend ertüchtigen und sie
unterstützen wird die Ukraine verlieren
das kann ich in unserem Interesse sein
erste Aussage und je länger wir warten
mit Waffenlieferung oder je länger die
dauern desto länger dauert der kriegt
das Auto
und da geht es natürlich nicht nur um
uns um Deutschland und die
Waffenlieferungen sondern es ist ja auch
spannend darauf zu schauen was machen
andere Länder andere Bündnispartner von
uns wir warten heute natürlich auch noch
im Laufe des Tages darauf dass die
Amerikaner sich nun offiziell äußern
gestern Medien Berichte ich erinnere
noch mal daran dass also auch von
amerikanischer Seite Kampfpanzer kommen
sollen was mich noch interessieren würde
ist wie sieht es denn aus mit anderen
Ländern Stichwort jetzt Polen Finnland
Niederlande auch über die Polen haben
wir ja gesprochen aber eben auch
Finnland sei offenbar bereit die Ukraine
mit Leoparden zu beliefern und auch die
Niederlande scheinen offen dafür dass
die Rede von 18 also von Deutschland ich
sag jetzt mal genießen Leopard Panzern
diese zur Verfügung zu stellen da ist
wohl der niederländische premier auch
der Meinung wir haben sie genießt das
heißt dass wir sie kaufen können das
heißt dass wir spenden können wir
schätzen sie das ein was wird da jetzt
anderen Ländern erlaubt werden von
deutscher Seite da war heute nicht so
viel drin in der regierungsbefragung
also ich gehe davon aus dass Polen die
14 angekündigten kampfkonsoleopard 2
liefern wird und wahrscheinlich auch
sehr schnell
Abhängigkeit von Ausbildung und
Logistiker ich vorhin angesprochen
ich gehe davon aus dass Finnland auch
dazu bereit sein wird und Finnland hat
ja in dieser Frage eine Sonderstatus
Finnland ist ein Land der Europäischen
Union aber bisher kein NATO Mitglied von
daher springt auch wenn die Absicht
besteht sie in die NATO aufzunehmen und
Finnland Mitglied werden will so ist das
zurzeit noch eine etwas andere Situation
bei den finden und Finger hat ja noch
ein anderes Problem es hat eine Grenze
von fast 1.000 300 km gemeinsam mit
Russland das heißt da ist vielleicht
auch dann für Kinder noch ein größeres
Risiko aber die finden haben Panzer für
ihre Reserve Verbände in der Reserve von
daher für den das möglicherweise
leichter Panzer abzugeben Leopard 2
abzugeben als es unfällt unfällt ich
möchte aber noch mal neben den
Niederlanden mit den genießen Panzern
die man kaufen kann und dann der Ukraine
Anführungszeichen schenken kann
Anführungszeichen
auch noch mal auf Spanien zurückkommen
die Spanier haben Mitte dieses Jahres im
Frühsommer ein Angebot gemacht Leopard 2
älteres Modell zu liefern die Spanier
haben damals keine Exportgenehmigung
dafür bekommen ich weiß nicht weil ich
da nicht drin sitze ob sie danach
gefragt haben aber auch die Spanier
sollte man noch mal ermutigen darüber
nachzudenken möglicherweise die
Instandsetzung dann mit den Spanien
gemeinsam bezahlen und da könnte man da
über diesen Weg die Zahl erhöhen diese
von Spanien damals angesprochen 40
Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 sind Depot
Bestände für verwende die irgendwann mal
im Rahmen der spanischen Verteidigung
aufgestellt wurden im natoran werden
zurzeit in Spanien nicht benötigt und
zweite Anmerkung von meiner Seite im
Gegensatz zu Polen oder das Slowakei
oder anderen Ländern oder auch
Deutschland sind die Spanier ein
bisschen weiter weg von Russland und
haben damit aufgrund der Entfernung
alleine schon eine gewisse ich sag mal
höhere Sicherheit
von mir auch noch mal eine Anmerkung
denn also was Scholz zugesagt hat ist
also dass er die Anfrage der Polen
positiv genehmigt werden soll die Polen
haben grundsätzlich auch schon reagiert
das habe ich nämlich gerade gesehen bei
Twitter also haben auf die deutsche
Entscheidung reagiert und zwar schrieb
hier die polnische Regierung danke
Kanzler Olaf Scholz schrieb der
Ministerpräsident heute am Mittwoch die
Entscheidung Leopard panzani Ukraine zu
schicken seit Zitat ein großer Schritt
dahin die russische Invasion zu stoppen
Zitat gemeinsam sind wir stärker also
das sind jetzt wirklich ganz andere Töne
als eben noch in den letzten Tagen als
man sich so gar nicht einziehen mit den
Bündnispartner
ganz kurz einhaken bitte man muss sich
darüber im Klaren sein dass wir mit
Polen in den 90er Jahren also nach der
deutschen Einigung und nach dem
Gesprächen und ich sag mal
freundschaftsverträgen die damals unter
Helmut Kohl geschlossen worden sind in
den letzten
Wochen Monaten vielleicht kann man sogar
schon von fast einem Jahr reden auch in
diesen Fragen Umgang mit der Ukraine als
zum Teil sehr angespanntes Verhältnis
gehabt haben und von daher haben die
Polen die ja auch näher dran sind und
das ist eine Erfahrung von mir die ich
als ich in Polen
kommandierender General eines Kurs wahr
gemacht habe ein ganz anderes Empfinden
gegenüber Russland als wir das haben
weil wir auch schon wieder ein bisschen
Abstand haben dabei das heißt je näher
die Staaten dran sind das gilt für die
Balken das gilt für die Polen das gilt
für die Slowakei und andere Stärken die
unmittelbare Nachbarschaft zu Russland
oder zurück keine haben oder zu
Weißrussland haben sage ich vielleicht
besser haben ein anderes Druckgefühl in
dieser Richtung und wir müssen uns
vielleicht auch manchmal in die
Perfektion dieser Staaten reinversetzen
der Blick auf eine solche Situation
Kriegen im Nachbarland
zum Schluss vielleicht noch mal eine
ganz praktische Frage die von Niklas
Kreis pointig bei Youtube kommt er fragt
sich denn wie lange wird die Ausbildung
der leopardbesatzung ungefähr dauern es
ist zwar gut dass sie geliefert werden
aber wann kann man sie dann effektiv
einsetzen
ich hatte vorhin schon von den sechs bis
acht Wochen gesprochen das hängt davon
ab wie schnell das diese Ausbildung an
beginnt ich gehe mal davon aus dass die
Ausbildung dieser Soldaten ukrainischen
Soldaten in Münster an der Panzer
truppenschule stattfinden wird von daher
dort erfahrenes ausbilderpersonal dort
sind auch entsprechende Leopard 2
vorhanden und dort kann man die Soldaten
schnell ausbilden ich komme mal zurück
auf das alte Beispiel des Gepard dort
hat es Fachleute gegeben die haben davon
gesprochen dass die Ausbildung auf dem
Gepard ein halbes Jahr oder vielleicht
sogar ein Jahr dauern würde die
Ausbildung beim Gebhard hat gedauert und
das hatten System ist komplett
42 Tage man wollte das ursprünglich
verkürzen auf drei Wochen also 21 Tagen
und auf Antrag der ukrainische Soldaten
die ausgebildet wurden hat man die
Ausbildung verlängert auf 42 Tage
spricht da reden wir über sechs Wochen
das ist einer der Anhaltspunkte die ich
nehme inklusive Lieferung Aufbau der
logistiken dass ich sage ich denke dass
diese Wagen sich sechs bis acht Wochen
in der Ukraine auswirken können sagt
generell General aD Egon Rams danke dass
Sie zu Gast war
gerne
und danke euch wer so lange zugeschaut
hat das war ein langes ZDF heute live
heute mit vielen Fragen vielen Antworten
an Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz wie gesagt
wer noch nicht genug hat ein was nun und
ein zdf-spezial heute Abend bei uns im
Programm und bis dahin sage ich danke
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss